so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
hello
what is up hi guys welcome back to the
dope as usual podcast i am thomas
dopaziola whatever you want to call me i
am with marty o'neil drastic graphics
what's up folks so excited to be here
today we got big energy today big news
let's go good day good stuff and marty
did not start it off with cussing i
almost threw this mark i saw you i saw
you uh we're trying to be on youtube's
nice side as we say every episode guys
this is the dope as usual podcast we're
gonna talk about talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between and today is
about everything in between all right
let's get started on this episode before
we even start i'm gonna start doing this
before we start do us a favor leave a
like on this video right now right below
leave a like it helps the algorithm
start it helps everything
share it with a friend i don't know just
press share there's a share button send
it to a homie go watch this and
hopefully next week they'll be sending
it to you but where are you at in the
chat so that's where we want to go and
from here instagram if you want to see
way more stuff we post a lot it's dope
as usual podcast on instagram all right
it's this
right there where you go in the youtube
about section just click it has all our
social media stuff um it has everything
actually our twitter is the same thing
uh link everything is in the uh header
of youtube if not just go in the about
section it has everything
now that i got that out of the way
because we never talk about it now that
we got that out of the way let's get
into this episode how are you guys it
has been
about six weeks about six weeks since
the solo huh yeah
it's been a while so much [ __ ] has
happened yeah it's a and as i was
writing the notes out i went there's so
much that's happened have i have i
talked about this yet i don't know all
right so we're going to start off with
the freshest stuff marty and i are you
ready we have some really really really
cool news for you guys
uh marty as you can you see my notes oh
yeah you see number one after latest and
great oh this section's called latest
and greatest all right let's gonna talk
about the latest stuff we're doing we
should have a section called
yeah we lost like when stuff doesn't
work out so we lost today yeah weakest
and bleakest the weakest
were you a rapper or something
right now
okay um go ahead start that off what's
that first one right there marty
okay yeah latest and greatest have been
this hold on where are we at here this
is going to be i know i want to one up
yeah okay yeah we're about to do away
with this ten minute clock pretty strong
folks we're trying right now pretty soon
we're trying to we're trying to
eliminate all these eggshells we walk
upon
that's true it's looking like we might
be getting rid of these eggshells pretty
soon
so that leads us into this next part
yeah
go first yeah say the first one and then
we'll we'll knock it out okay yeah i
mean we got
well let's just set the scene here a
little bit yeah we'll set the scene here
a little bit because we're a youtube
community here
but this is a podcast
podcasts come out on all the audio
platforms too that be true there's a
whole
community of people on the audio side of
things that aren't on youtube that
probably love this show just as much if
they were to know about it that's true
they're not on youtube they might not
even know about the show we're still
relatively new and we don't pay for any
promotion
yes so
that's a good setup yeah we've been
great we take on the mind state of we're
going to stir up as much momentum as we
possibly can and they're going to
they're going to notice somebody's going
to know someone's going to call yeah
somebody's going to notice this so we uh
we got that call finally
let's go from [ __ ]
spotify oh spotify so last weekend
or last friday marty texted me and i
just saw a bunch of emojis oh what what
happened and my text i think says and i
read it spotify spotify reached out to
us guys and today we'd love to hop on a
call with you and see what we can do
yeah
yeah yes bottom to answer one of our
most highly fan requested
things of all time guys the dober's
usual podcast marty and i are going to
start up you can watch us on spotify
right now listen to us but starting
monday with this episode and you might
be watching it on spotify and if you are
watching it in the car don't do that
just listen please be safe drive careful
please
as i'm drinking this beer don't drink a
drive either okay um
we are one of the very few shows we did
the math 0.04004
of shows
and we got a lot they actually onboarded
us we're going to have our own video
uploading so there's no more just audio
if you go on spotify and dope as usual
now you click us in it's video all right
just like [ __ ] joe rogan and all
those other big [ __ ] yes
we're gonna go we're gonna go back and
put up the old ones all the new ones and
beyond that spotify is going to be
showing us some [ __ ] love they
said we're going to push your [ __ ]
show we want to push your show to new
audiences
let's go thanks
thank you that's what the [ __ ] we want
to do
exactly so first off starting this
episode off spotify shout out to you
because that was [ __ ] cool
super cool super awesome it's always
awesome when it's like we're not being
we're not aggressively reaching out
trying to make something happen and
something just comes down the pipe like
that that the fans want that's gonna let
us grow the show that's it's just all in
the green for us we're we're super happy
about that and he started off with
so i've been watching these episodes and
he was like i love it it's [ __ ] fun
all right yeah the spotify dudes so i've
been watching the show yes they're
starting to turn these corporations
they're still
i know it's like you watched it the [ __ ]
did you you guys had [ __ ] sold packs
oh you're fine with it
this is gonna be good i feel like we're
getting more on the same page yeah these
with these big people so hell yeah so
that's the first bit of huge
awesome cool news so hopefully you're
watching this on spotify and if you're
not
watch on youtube just leave a little
like like i said earlier it helps helps
a lot um
so that's one big piece of news i wanted
to talk about real quick
what time are we at marty
it's five but we could call it time
uh 20 40 uh
100 120 100 you just pulled a smoky big
worm on me right now i mean uh
this bike's like both of ours yeah we
just keep it at my house
[ __ ] dj push out to dj for that
that's such a good line that's such a
good life okay here we go this next
piece of information i'm only gonna say
a piece and i'm not gonna say much and
i'm just gonna tease the [ __ ] out of you
marty look at marty's face and my face
we got the coolest [ __ ] news
ever
for this podcast we're not going to tell
you what it is i'm just going to leave
you like that we have some news that may
or may not send us into the [ __ ]
stratosphere of [ __ ] and it's going to
happen it's 100 gonna happen
and they are on board let's just say
this the people we're about to start
working with
they are our kind of people they look at
us and go oh you want to do skits and
fun [ __ ]
yes that's what we live for [ __ ]
oh good perfect
uh so the podcast is about to get
a little more intense yeah we've been
playing chess for a long time with these
with these
certain people people within this
industry this industry is very new like
we always talk about like we always talk
about you can look at music and see what
happened to music and kind of look at
podcasting and kind of see how these
labels and all you know the big deals
are formed and where all the money is
and it's happening and podcasting right
now there's these giant deals that are
set in precedence in this industry
and we're [ __ ] with these big some of
the big people in this industry that are
looking at us and seeing what these next
10 years look like with this
[ __ ] dope as usual and i quote
this show is going to be the joe rogan
uh for the next generation that's what
they quoted us as yeah and we've seen
that million times in the [ __ ]
comments just happy that uh
those guys were like yeah that's how we
see it let's work yeah
[ __ ] yeah so as far as the show goes
there's gonna be some
some real visible
improvements over the next couple months
but
some of the behind-the-scenes stuff
that's just going to make our lives so
much [ __ ] better
is uh is what's going to really be
prevalent and pretty
pretty immediate but this is a situation
that's going to kind of roll out over
the year
i'm just going to leave you guys yeah
all right let's just say when it happens
we'll [ __ ] i'm going to throw up on
this table and be so happy yeah it's
going to happen yeah just waiting for
that contract elevate the show yeah
yeah [ __ ] is chess i've done this before
with other shows
i know how this is going to go
and it's like one of these things that i
preach about working relationships the
the most important thing you can have is
your relationships and how you work them
just knowing when the time is right to
play the right cards and sometimes [ __ ]
just lines up
and
this [ __ ] is chess it really is half of
the reason the reason why this is
successful is because of just the way we
connect the dots like
the fact that we were able to get all
these guests up until this point
or just to be able to do all this like
because people don't they go like why
don't you have snoop dogg and am
sandwich you guys have to remember
those are on an upper echelon of guests
where it's like yo i don't know who
those guys are they're just getting high
in a room what if they rob me i don't
want to put what if that guy turns out
to be a creep and i just went on his
[ __ ] podcast i don't know anything
about this guy meaning us meaning us
yeah so that i could see why they're
like they're manager's like no bro you
see the story times talking about doing
meth and [ __ ]
that's why we're trying to like
hey
i cannot be the weed guy too that
doesn't when you build it up to a
certain level that doesn't matter
anymore yes but right now we are yeah
exactly we're on we're on that medium
level of where people might still be a
little sketched out
just because we're not fake we're not
like famous people coming into this
exactly we're not most podcasts start
with famous [ __ ]
remember that like almost 99 of the time
if you come into podcasting not famous
you're fighting a [ __ ] uphill battle
100
you know we have a fan base we have a
we're not famous
it does fame gets you access right they
get you asking people trust you and go
he doesn't want to lose that i can trust
him coming here he's not going to rob me
that's the most [ __ ] thing like
is it for going to rob me is we're going
to [ __ ] send some people that's how i
think so i don't like [ __ ]
around me like oh yeah you yeah i saw
you looking at that [ __ ] now i'm gonna
get robbed like [ __ ] a trust a trust
just comes from just like just seeing it
out there becoming aware of it becoming
aware like knowing that it's a good look
for you that's all that that's the only
reason why half you know people come on
is because
they want to get in front of that big
community and be a part of something
cool so and most of the people we pick
we're like you know the guests the fans
this is going to resonate well a lot of
that is for you guys we
we try to coordinate certain guests like
this like last episode
perfect example last episode's different
that was you guys you guys asked for
that if you haven't seen it yet boom
over the screen right now the larry
lawton episode america's biggest jewel
thief
please watch that episode i cut it short
at two and a half hours because i didn't
want to keep going because i want him to
come back all right he's like
he's my [ __ ] a story machine i know
there's so many in there i loved his
energy so much he was such a nice guys
right off the bat larry lon [ __ ] cool
ass dude yeah super cool [ __ ]
man like i could tell right away like
this fool is real as hell
off camera how much you respected you
respected the show sometimes you get
dudes that have been in like you know
like prison and [ __ ] harder dudes they
come in and they just have alpha energy
yes like he had he was cool he like
respected this he was came to have fun
yeah
came to have fun yes he had fun that man
was [ __ ] high when he left
he even texted me yeah last night he
goes man i'm surprised you know i kept
up like that well it was like i think i
did i'm like dude you did great you
smoked everything and [ __ ] smoked a
cigar and chilled like it was great and
you kept conversation yes sorry i know
we're going off topic but that was great
um so we're gonna leave you with that
podcast is about
to levels to the show yeah it's about to
get on the next step yeah excited yeah
it's not just me and marty anymore it's
gonna be
we have a full team meaning
not like
you don't see yeah exactly bts meaning
when we're dealing with these big
companies
we have better representation that's the
real goal because it's it's
representation that's really what it is
you get up to a certain level like on
all the commercial shoots i deal with
the talent isn't dealing directly with
anybody no if you want to deal with the
talent you got to deal with their team
yeah it's unheard of on that level so
it's like we got to understand what
level we're working towards and just
keep
leveling up so we get [ __ ] on we're like
uh hey we got the big kid on the
playground to [ __ ] follow it no no
we're allowed to come in here man with
them
that's basically where they hey
they're cool don't worry i know yeah
drugs i get it i get it just let him
come in and hopefully provide us some
protection from this beautiful platform
around here this nice youtube platform
that loves us so much not the fan the
fans are great i'm talking about the
youtube
they are not feeling us so it's okay
it's okay how nice would it be if we
could not be worried all the time how
cool would it be if i could just rip my
bong right now like joey diaz does yeah
but remember they're famous first so
that's where we're on i won't dwell on
any more
hopefully super soon
let's go it's about to go it's about to
go
oh [ __ ] he scared me damn that did scare
me yeah okay um on my next little latest
and greatest topic
if you've been watching the podcast
since the start you remember last year
excuse me so sorry
you remember last year i said i went to
the doctor the gastrointestinal doctor
because my stomach was hurting for like
10 years all right so i finally went
and he's like yo you have something
called h pylori it's a [ __ ] virus you
get from old food or old water
in third world countries
and through a world country i don't know
how i got it
i don't know how i [ __ ] got it but my
stomach's been hurting since
10 years now and he told me like this
can last up to a decade 15. some people
don't even notice but until it starts
hurting like you so i went in last year
we talked about it guys we talked about
on the show i [ __ ] took the pills all
the vitamins all the stuff my stomach
started hurting again a month ago so i
go back he tests me goes you're positive
still completely positive like nothing
ever happened
we called cvs to make sure that they
gave me the right dosage cvs gave me the
wrong antibiotics
so just this whole time this whole time
just nothing changed and i'm sure
they're very sorry and they no they told
me i was an [ __ ] and the doctor
like yeah he never picked that up though
like
but you gave me the stuff i ordered
yeah uh well let me get back on the
phone and then they just kept putting us
on hold i'm like okay
okay so anyway i'm on the vitamins now i
mean the vitamins i'm on the antibiotics
now guys i have the super bad stomach
pains it sucks it's not fun
anyway that's the update from last year
last from season one when i talked about
this yeah when i thought it was all good
after i was doing the vitamins my
stomach feels a little better
i just kept it moving and then it
started hurting so bad i went back and
goes bro you never took these i guess i
[ __ ] did and that's what we found out
so anyway
[ __ ] cvs
that's the update with my stomach it
still hurts i'm still trying to figure
it out
um yeah
[ __ ] cvs [ __ ] cvs man give me those two
mile long receipts [ __ ] cvs they don't
care about my stomach or trees
okay and i love both of those things
pushing them speaking of which
speaking of which hold on
uh joint break here we go
first joint of the episode thank you
rosie for giving me this
extravagant
extravagant baller ass ashtray oh yeah
hold on
oh yeah yeah marty's got one too [ __ ]
excuse me bomb
type of [ __ ] you put your [ __ ] gold
in in the 20s
you know what i'm saying like i don't
know it just reminds me of that next
episode i'm coming with the scotch glass
with the little [ __ ] bottle and [ __ ]
i'm gonna that'd be kind of cool i would
turn around out of that villain in my
chair that'd be cool
wait that [ __ ] don't have wheels
figured out okay that chair has no
wheels marty here we go here we go joint
break
next topic what do we have i'm gonna say
14.
i had the genius idea to put a stop
clock on the [ __ ] thing but then i
forgot the screen but then i forgot
here we go
once again real quick if you're watching
on spotify thank you very much
appreciate you so much if you're
watching on youtube thank you
thank you for being in the chat let's
get started that just made me so happy
when you said that so hard huh
people ask all the time how come we
don't have that option like they don't
give us it what the [ __ ] and he goes the
guy said at the end of the spotify
meeting now you have a contact a point
of contact please do you need anything
oh my god we never had a point of
contact at anything yeah seriously so
he's here's an email so nice that was
honestly one of the best days ever this
was just what all this happened was just
two hours yeah
yes so thank you guys we want to keep
you updated on all this [ __ ] i know we
gotta we can't really fully come out and
talk what we're talking about but just
not yet because we're not when shit's
all done it's done but this is big [ __ ]
this is
the biggest game changing [ __ ] for the
show by far the biggest thing we've ever
done anywhere
we just signed this miller light deal so
we've been yes
we've been yeah we've been i'm just very
grateful that we're able to keep going
up these levels yep
thank you guys for watching
here we go
my next thing
real quick i'll touch on it
last week on the dopeziola uh youtube
channel i did the very first video ever
for push trees push trees my company
pushtrees.com
i've had it for eight years
never did a video on it on the dopagiola
channel
the biggest [ __ ] platform of cannabis
in the world and i've never
put my
own company on it i mean i wear the
shirts yeah
use a bong i've never just gone so guys
this is what the [ __ ] we do when we make
let me just say if you watch that video
thank you first non-age restricted video
in a long time
all right
oh you had that [ __ ] ready
love that that was a good one
um if you watch that thank you so much
thank you so [ __ ] much
guys i've never done a video right
i
i was out of town all weekend on friday
saturday sunday i was a nap at my
friend's wedding
so friday we did the the video i didn't
check the sales tool yesterday morning
yo
[ __ ] off for real
the ups guy said all right the ups truck
driver said
i think i need another truck because i
don't know if i'm able to fit this in my
truck
a truck
yes like that's a lot of orders
[ __ ] yes
so guys we
we did a lot of [ __ ] orders this
weekend so thank you so much thank you
so [ __ ] much that's all i was going
to say the push trees drop push
trees.com
oh this new marty's wearing the [ __ ]
sweater also
push trees we got a bunch of gear if you
want to check it out it's called
pushtrees2022
that's the new video on the dopazola
channel or push tree stock i am high i
need to re-light this and i almost went
like this
i'm burned i'm [ __ ]
wow okay um push trees 20 22 for
everyone in the car i almost tried to
light my joint with a can of beer um
[ __ ] off so yeah go watch it
pushtrees.com thank you guys so much for
watching thank you so much for
supporting
yeah so i just want to say that thank
you this weekend holy [ __ ] [ __ ] there
was a lot of orders i got to do more
videos yeah because we sell great
we sold amazing this weekend
[ __ ]
every drop is so sick it is it oh also
for everyone out there that got the new
clothes
yes these are different blanks shout out
to claudio from the dopa shop all right
one of my partners adobe shop he made
dopest uh a shirt just for me to wear
and i put it on and went what blank is
this
i've never felt that blank it's the best
blank i've ever [ __ ] felt the blank
tease and i only use it for push trees
now i will not ever use another blank i
went seven years using the same blank
and found a one that i mean it's double
the price it is double the price worth
it i only raised the [ __ ] shirts a
doll oh two dollars
but it's like a five dollar extra shirt
um i'll take a little lost but bro wow
so if you get any of the new clothes man
i've watched this shirt six [ __ ]
times the the push three shirt
and it hasn't [ __ ] lost the shape yet
and i'm just my neck is still there no
bacon next [ __ ]
oh my god especially if you're a fat
dude you know that [ __ ] you get a little
pull it's like oh your whole outfit's
you look like a kid with the [ __ ]
wipes your mouth on their shirt oh you
know what i mean like it's just like
hanging in [ __ ] it's the worst
but that's what i'm trying to say
pushtrees.com thank you guys so [ __ ]
much for supporting that
really appreciate it let me get on to
this uh
story time all right i got story time
coming at you guys it's been a minute
since we've had a solo episode all right
it's been a long time
so i wanted to throw the story time and
it is very brief
but i want you to get inside my head
so you could feel what i felt
there's another story of this episode
but for this one i'm going to leave you
with the sh i want to start you off with
a short one
i haven't told you marty
are you [ __ ] ready
yes let's set the scene
i'm fat right i'm not in shape
i've been going to a trainer i've been
trying
it's working a little all right you're
crushing it don't just doing good right
so i have to get fitted for a tuxedo
for my friend's wedding i was one of the
groomsmen
so
i get my tuxedo it fits
never worn tuxedo my life
i felt like the little brother from
christmas story that i was oh i can't
you know i kept my arms down kid with
all the jackets that's how i felt with
one layer on
bro this is how p and i even said limo
drivers and [ __ ] that wear this
[ __ ] gotta get tip more this is
uncomfortable i've never worn dress
shoes in my entire life even to funerals
i mean dress shoes you lace i get the
slip-on ones
bro
ready
let me set the scene
i get my pants get everything and
they're too long so i have them hem it
i'm like you know what let's taper it in
my legs are big but let's taper it in a
little bit thank you don't try them on
i i trusted the guy after i don't try
him on because he did it he's like yeah
it's fine oh okay like i don't travel
like it's cool
the length what do you make the waist
smaller no
well fine
and then oh yeah stop telling
[ __ ] to get belts that are that
are fat we don't need a belt okay so and
the thing is must wear black belt for a
tuxedo no not wearing a [ __ ] belt
so here we go
i get my stuff
i go to napa
i put my clothes on
the morning of rosie's the bridesmaid
rosie's already at the spot getting
ready at 8 in the morning i don't be
there to 10 45 it's 10 o'clock putting
my stuff on i'm like probably should
have tried all this on first
you know it's been like a week since i
got i should probably try it on first
just in case
you ready
i put this [ __ ] white shirt on you
guys might have seen me on instagram i
posted it put this white shirt on bow
tie have no idea so i'm letting the
[ __ ] hang i'm let's wait for somebody
to help me at the spot
i put the blazer coat tuxedo thing on
i'm like this
right
i can't put my shoes on if i bend that
shirt's done
if i bend too much the pants are oh i
haven't told you about the pants put the
shirt on before the blazer put the pants
on
this [ __ ] cut the leg so skinny
marty
i couldn't bend
or the mid would rip
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying like they
were good pants i'm like yeah make a
little short taper like from the calf
like the calf park it was baggy
this full tapered the groin to the knee
oh
god you know what i'm saying like almost
like it was too short so i'm putting my
pants on like
i'm a [ __ ] grossman no
the wedding starts in two [ __ ] hours
and i have them on i'm like this i'm
stiff
or i can't move like you know if you
bend if you put your knees outward and
squat down to grab something they're
done
so i'm feeling more horrible about
myself than i ever have thinking like yo
i need to step this trainer [ __ ] up this
is not for me don't like this
haven't put the shoes on yet
you've worn
like dress shoes they're real tight ones
that are pointy
with the [ __ ] laces i've never put
them on my life i haven't either i hated
it yeah so i get to the venue and i'm
losing i'm like yo 10 45 it's 10 47 i
hate being late
only person in the parking lot
so i'm like okay [ __ ] it at a wedding
well the wedding is until one or two
we're gonna get there for pictures get
high as [ __ ] first with my homie that
the bride the groom he gets a high [ __ ]
so i get there guys i'm like all right
instead of vineyard
so you know it's pretty breezy it's a
napa it's nice as [ __ ] it's at an old
barn it looks cool [ __ ]
oh my god let's get these shoes on i
unleash the shoes guys i cannot get it's
like trying to get my fist in this can
like i put my foot in and i got only
past my toes went no [ __ ] way these
don't fit
i was like no way all right i'm gonna
look up a store this is not gonna fit
and when somebody showed he goes just
try to like
tug them open because they take a while
to open up
i tug them open guys as i get them open
like i think i get my foot in this
i throw it on the ground because i can't
bend i throw it on the ground so i can
put my foot in and try to like get my
[ __ ] in because i can't bend over
and i slide my foot in i know i scraped
the skin off the back of my ankle trying
to get my foot you know what i'm saying
imagine this guys and imagine if you're
not fat just imagine
having too big of a jacket on and you
can't bend
that's what feeds fat's like okay
so i'm sitting there like all right all
right i'm standing right in front of my
rental it's in a dirt field
so i have my hand on there i'm like dude
don't fall i just don't fall i have the
jacket off i have just a white shirt
with a bow tie hanging
look like a waiter you looked classy
when i saw you that was when i was done
up okay
at this point i look oh you know what i
compared it to guys
i now get why in bugs bunny cartoons
when he's yelling at the opera singer
and his butt's going
when he's singing
that's how i felt was going to happen
like if i move
it's done [ __ ] this is done it's going
to pop then i noticed my blazer they
gave me the wrong blazer supposed to
have one button that gave me [ __ ] two
okay so the whole wedding i'm standing
there like this
the kick to cover the button and [ __ ]
but every time i was just like posing i
wasn't posing i was just trying to cover
this button it didn't match the rest of
the yes
so anyway i'm there
i get my foot in this guy's it gets
worse it gets way better hold on it gets
better if you if you like people's
demise and [ __ ] this is better for you
i get my foot on there and they go all
right
pouring sweat tripping sweat it's not
cold in napa oh i'm in a full outfit 10
45 in the morning sweating in the field
rosie's not there to help me and i'm
like okay
i'm gonna have to get undressed to get
my shoes on
in there i took my [ __ ] pants down
dropped my shirt
like picked it up and bent over
almost
where i couldn't feel it i mean where i
couldn't reach because the pants guys
i'm standing legs spread
trying not to rip the pants you know
okay but also try not to fall in the
dirt yeah there's no seats
if i can't sit in my own car sideways
and get my shoe on because the pants
will rip
so i'm just like oh trying to lace them
as fast as i can hold on
pants are too tight to put the pants on
after the shoes
right yes
we'll get into that
this is ten percent oh okay this gets so
much worse
i said short story it's not a short
story i get so much worse
i get the shoe one and go
oh my god i've never felt claustrophobic
before
and i felt claustrophobic in my body
okay my feet felt like i couldn't open
my toes i couldn't oh i spread my toes
at all like it was so bad i felt the
bone on the side like like this you know
in like the 1400s and they make the
asian girls clog their feet square
ballerinas that's how i felt
and i'm sitting there and i keep
thinking about all the people in history
like you [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
could you imagine being an asian lady in
the 1500s you have to make your feet
square
remember that [ __ ] they put them in the
shoes and your feet have to [ __ ] grow
into it as a kid and their feet are
squared like this i don't know and their
toes curl under
you never seen that it's like a if
you're got money
that's what you do because you have
smaller feet that's how i felt sorry
that's how i felt remember guys i got
one shoe on
so i put my other shoe on and i'm like
all right cool pick my pants up
button my pants zip them up
do a little slight squat to get my pants
in
zipper just rips right in half damn
zipper just rips breaks
breaks
okay
[ __ ] breaks okay i didn't think you're
gonna say that oh my god and as he does
that the groomsmen pulls up in his car
and go zipper just broke because don't
tell me that
my zipper's broken
what do we do
he goes all right
my it's his friend's property so his
house is right there too on this big ass
lake land
uh rubello wine
the wine company that's where we're at
he's in that but he knows all the dudes
um
i go up the guy's cool [ __ ] he's cool
guy i met him before anyway
he goes hey
he's like you got some electrical tape
and as i said that one of you goes these
are mexicans you know there's electrical
that's what i was thinking i don't think
you're gonna say that
but it's fine i don't give a [ __ ] and
i'm like you know he does it's in his
pocket
we went over there and he goes yeah
opens his door it's right there in his
truck yeah of course i get some
electrical tape try to put it in the
inside of my guys i would have never
thought remember hold on i'm sorry
thursday i slipped the disc in my back
again or whatever been to the
chiropractor can't really bend over too
well marty to begin with to begin with
so remember my back is so stiff and i'm
trying to bend over that's why i said i
held my breath like oh my back [ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry my back is really hurting
so i'm sitting there trying to look down
put my back hurts so i'm like
[ __ ] getting red just trying to look
down
and i put the tape on the inside of my
zipper it doesn't work it's fabric it's
not going to work i know it doesn't work
he goes all right safety pins and i go
mundo my homie i can't bend
i can't i can't he goes
i got you who's got a safety pin laying
around though the guy had two big ass
ones what the [ __ ] we're at his house i
don't know oh okay with the guy's house
he's right next to the barn thing catch
this property
i'm gonna grab my pants i'm gonna pull
them as far away from my dick as i
possibly can
and put the clip in there for three and
a half minutes moon is on one knee
eye level just trying to get this thing
then i'm like who is that and it's the
photographer and the target is like oh
no no i'm getting this i'm waiting for
the pictures he must have snapped 30
pictures of this one and me like that
one of me like fully dressed trying to
fix the zipper right before the win
felt so stupid right
didn't work
didn't work oh then i go to the guy that
owns the spot and he goes
i used to be a lot bigger man
i might have some pants that fit you
[ __ ] cool
thanks for saying it that way but yeah
let me get those pants [ __ ] he
goes in same exact pants i got they're
exactly the same length as my [ __ ]
leg like what are the [ __ ] odds he
goes yeah go my wack room his wife's
like go in the back room you can lock
the door and either fix it with the tip
things or treat the other pants
this is where i really felt bad and
stupid and played and fat as [ __ ]
are you guys ready for this [ __ ]
this is where it gets bad not the dick
thing not the clip none of that stuff
all that was [ __ ] all right
this is where it gets bad this is why
story time will never die yeah this is a
12-minute ordeal 20-minute ordeal that
happened to me and i'm still talking
about it this happened four days ago are
you ready
i don't think things through take the
jacket off put it on this person's bed
in their room i've never been in because
they allow me to go in their house
i just feel bad i have the pants that
he's like might fit you my back up i'm
gonna try to fix these ones first
i'm trying to fix the clip first okay
i'm not sweating pouring in the sun so
i'm like all right i'm just trying to do
it so i'm doing it
and i get it
and i stand up and right when i like
stand up and she just breaks i go bro i
had it because it was right up the
zipper is gonna do this
and just show my underwear during the
wedding walking down the aisle bro come
on stop all the pictures all the time
everything right
so
this is where it gets bad marty i need
you to pay attention i'm gonna put this
joint down
okay
jack it off
white shirt bow tie hanging
shoes that hurt
you know when you take your pants down
over your shoes you use one foot to
stand on a leg and you pull your foot
out yeah you use other foot and you pull
your foot out very standard very
standard or when you're down you kick
the keel off and you know you take your
shoes off out of the pants okay
marty
i pull the pants down remember shirt
will rip too i was gonna get butt ass
[ __ ] barenake in this lady's bedroom
so i'm like i'll keep the shirt on
i take the pants down and as i take the
pants down you know the the the pants
are over my shoes i can't see my shoes
because the pants are over and you pull
them out the heel's too big to get the
pants out
i start trying to stand on one thing
they're dress pants all i'm doing is
sliding
off of these shoes the shoes are sliding
they're brand new [ __ ] shoes they're
so slick
i try to stand on the pant leg and the
pressure from me pulling is pulling the
pants out from under me and i sat there
look down and go i'm stuck
i am [ __ ] stuck with my pants down
i can't move
i can't bend over to take my shoes off
marty because my back is so hurt
so i can't bend down and just pull my
shoe off like a normal human yeah so i'm
trying to stand and go and kick them off
and kick them off and it keeps going
sliding
there's no way i'm about to call my
[ __ ] friend and go yo can you pull
these pants off
i grabbed my phone and went let me try
again before i call this pool
meanwhile the fools that are gardening
this guy's property
right in the window of the bedroom
right there big-ass hat with a lawn
mower
and i'm looking at them there's no
blinds or curtains because they're in
the country why'd you need them
and i'm just looking this guy he's
looking at me i'm like
sup
wanna help me with these pants
[ __ ]
so marty you're so beautiful yeah i look
down i can't see my feet i just see my
pants inside out in front of me and
everywhere i can't walk and spread
because they're so tapered and my back
hurts so i can't bend over and get it
do you see rosie's not there rosie's not
there she won't be there for an hour you
just had a dude pictures will be taken
in 20 minutes for the photographer
that's why we got there early for the
groomsmen pictures
so about three minutes in guys i'm just
sliding
trying to get these [ __ ] shoes off
and i keep pulling as hard as i can on
my feet and i see one heel pop out and i
go okay this is real it's possible then
and i grip that heel with the shoe and
pop it off
and i'm pouring sweat from the anxiety
of yo i can't get my pants off i'm out
of shape in my back hurts that's how i
felt like am i a piece of [ __ ] i can't
get these own pants sorry for this story
it's still going it's your man's wedding
though this is high pressure [ __ ] yes
i'm not done yeah i get the pants off i
go [ __ ] these pants and i put his pants
on that he gave me put them on go oh you
weren't that fat full these are small as
[ __ ] thanks
these are too [ __ ] small i kick those
off and those are wide enough to kick
off with the shoes on i'm standing in
some stranger's bedroom with a long
white shirt bow tie undone underwear and
just shoot a dude
staring at and i was looking at him like
bro
cut the lawn over there
you got to get the window right now he
wasn't like staring at him but he looked
like i'm like
i'm stuck [ __ ] you my back if my back
didn't hurt i could have just bent over
and pulled him off anyway it's bad it's
bad so what i do guys
i get the safety pins on the pants on
the inside since they're off way easier
works put the pants on they break again
and i go done
pulled them off gave them all their
stuff back walk down go hey zipper's
broken still don't know what to do
didn't work he goes don't worry dude my
dad will be here he's good with stuff
like that like your dad's good with
dudes zippers and safety pins it's like
no like he's handy i go but he's a limo
driver
don't worry i'm a liberal driver exactly
i just quoted that irl yesterday in the
car oh [ __ ] don't worry
um
i'm walking the 40 80 yards back to my
car from the guy's house we're right
next to the venue
and i just do this
zipper fixes itself
i pull it up and it goes right back on
track marty and i go no no way
no [ __ ] way and i look down
i try to look down and it zipped up
it zipped up if it's this long it zipped
up this much okay i'm like leave it
alone don't even touch this [ __ ] i go
back and everybody's like so what are
you gonna do i go bro
i don't know how but look at the zippers
fixed they go
well don't touch it go i know don't
worry i won't
right after the ceremony i take one seat
button goes boom
but they're clips like so they don't and
button goes off i go dude i am out of
shape
i look down and go zipper broke again
so you know what i did
here's my pants on my body i turned my
pants to where my zippers on the side of
my head
and i continued the rest of the six
hours of this [ __ ] wedding
so whoever out there that saw me like yo
this hips are weird
nope just the pants so imagine dress
pants and a tuxedo buttoned up
i just twist them so the zipper's not
over my middle
wow that is my wedding story
popping out in the middle of the
ceremony yep
i felt so stupid
and out of shape
and my background i thought all of these
things are preventable
everything and you drove like eight
hours pulled away so my back hurt bad so
anyway
that was such a simple story i thought
it'd be short not sure oh that's good
but i hope that you guys could see
everything that happened i need to get
the pictures back yes
so anyway my [ __ ] homies wedding's
super fun um
and i know i know we we talk a lot of
[ __ ] on the raiders guys i get it it's
just i'm a packers fan we always talk to
you about the raiders because is there
another team blah blah blah but one of
the groomsmen my homie mundo's best home
one of his best homies is
jalen [ __ ] richard the [ __ ]
running back for the raiders
so i was chilling with this floor all
weekend like yo this is a funny ass
[ __ ] right all right maybe the
raiders are so bad man all right all
right so that was pretty [ __ ]
hilarious to me i'm like
you're the running back for the
you are the running back for the raiders
huh
so i was like oh
that's a lot of [ __ ] about the reason
this is okay
anyway i just he gets it he knows but uh
i just thought it was really funny i'm
like
dig my pop out
in front of all these people and
like this sucks we had a [ __ ] fiasco
on my wedding date i don't know if i you
told me yeah that you're
yeah
tell me what you tell them what you told
me same [ __ ] we had the whole rehearsal
and then on my actual wedding morning
everything was completely smooth up
through the morning of the wedding
my homeboy came and picked me up we rode
around [ __ ] puffed to dutch and [ __ ]
a little bit april was off getting ready
we're kind of just contemplating
you know kind of like no big deal we get
back to the house and he's like
oh i don't you know they didn't give me
a vest
you touch me a tuxedo junction i don't
know if that's a [ __ ] thing out here
but everybody had the same [ __ ] thing
from tuxedo junction
so malachi is all yeah i don't have a
[ __ ] fast they didn't give it to me
then jamel shows up he's got a [ __ ]
malcolm x bow tie on instead of our
tie that we all had and he's like [ __ ] i
don't know like he didn't know what
happened to his tie
so then i have to [ __ ]
send them off back to tuxedo junction
like what the [ __ ]
this is a wedding these fools probably
never i don't think any of us had been
to a wedding before but we all got to
wear the same thing we this is all
coordinated we can't be
freestyling what the [ __ ] we're wearing
this is when you show it to pe they give
you a shirt because you're very pe
clothes you have to wear it lost a found
shirt
so they were going to go like no it's
cool bro yeah like this what i had
we've been coordinating this [ __ ] for
months see i wish i had that mentality
man then we [ __ ]
now mind you i had already found out two
of my best friends were like
ah
sorry we can't make it got my daughter
today's reviews
just they just couldn't get a ride or
some [ __ ] like in buffalo yeah
yeah trust me you walk there yeah i
don't know man but i already kind of
knew that i wasn't even that bummed out
about it it was like on some i
understood
but then
so april's dad drives up he lives out in
the middle of nowhere he comes up to my
mom's house in lackawanna and he's gonna
follow us to the venue we pull out of
our little side street as soon as we
pull out of the side street
he's no longer behind us we can't find
him no cell vote no cell phones so now
we just pull over on the side and we're
like hoping he drives the place to the
wedding yes on the way to the wedding so
now
we're like
you know i got jemele and malachi going
back to the mall i'm hoping they're able
to get because i know april's gonna
[ __ ] freak out if she realizes that
two of my
best men have are not even there don't
have the matching [ __ ] and two and we're
not even there two nights
yeah yeah so
then one of my other best men so we we
find her dad he gets behind us we start
driving one of my other best men calls
and goes
what's up what's up store what are you
doing
uh going to the wedding what are you
doing you on your way
oh
it's today
[ __ ]
so my one of the
other best men forgot it was the [ __ ]
wedding on that day
so that
uh
that then we just then i i just kind of
laughed it off you had five groomers men
two of them didn't show up two showed up
in shorts
and then one was like oh yeah that's
right i'll be right there
basically [ __ ] yeah it's the two dudes
that didn't show up they were just they
weren't actually in the wedding they
were just like my best friends
the two dudes i mentioned at the
beginning which just kind of bummed me
out but yeah the other ones were all the
best groomsmen and what really bums me
out today is my homeboy dean
wasn't one of the groomsmen and he
[ __ ] should have been in it [ __ ] bums
me out
it was there but it was like looking
back today is still one of my closest
best friends and i just i feel i [ __ ]
wish he was uh up there with us and [ __ ]
but anyway i think that [ __ ] is normal
like little catastrophes and [ __ ]
fiascos and [ __ ] your [ __ ] was actually
but you gotta remember though no one
else is dripping this is just all meat
internally
everyone else is chilling
people that smoke weed are probably just
smoking weed and hanging out and not
even noticing yeah all your terror
you're going through
yeah and before we like get people in
trouble it's just like me and mundo
smoking weed and kurt
i'm not saying like i don't want to be
like you smoke a wee with nfl but no oh
yeah i don't want you like me getting
people in trouble like no we went to the
back of the barn and snuck off and
smoked while everybody was doing their
thing uh-huh because we're at his
wedding and his family's there
we did the same [ __ ] a big-ass group of
[ __ ] 12 of us come back just reeking
and [ __ ]
he was [ __ ] up i mean i was ripping my
ash pen like
uh anyway that was the catastrophe of
the wedding and that's marty's
catastrophe the wedding i'm so happy
that you threw that one on there right
now because
we both see look at everyone's the same
it's just things are tweaked a little
yeah oh you had a bad wedding
catastrophe so did i
here we go guys uh
yo what's up guys just want to take a
minute to thank the sponsor of today's
episode and that is miller lite so
before we get started guys do me a favor
go to millerlight.com forward slash yola
yes
our code all right forward slash yola
that's going to take you to a landing
page on their site that's going to show
you all the places around you that
deliver miller lite to your house or
we've said it before you can go to any
place on earth that sells beer and for
sure they got miller lite and guys
you've heard me talk about this in many
story times before and i'm not trying to
put any of the brands down you know i've
drink miller light for a very long time
but you guys already know from story
time i've talked about other light beers
not miller like because i actually like
middle light i've talked about other
light beers that taste like water they
taste like nothing miller lite has been
and always will be the light beer for
people that like beer taste example some
of us like soda not everybody likes diet
soda because diet sodas suck for the
most part miller lights for the people
that actually want to drink it and taste
beer now you guys have heard me say it
many times before drinking miller light
that taste that nostalgia takes me back
to the bonfires hanging out with my
friends hanging out with my uncle john
just having a great time that's what
this will always remind me of as always
celebrate responsibly from milwaukee
brewing company in milwaukee wisconsin
this is 96 calories 3.2 grams of carbs
for every can so before we get back to
the episode guys one more time go to
www.millerlight.com forward slash yola
that's going to take you the landing
page anywhere that delivers beer or once
again go to any single place on earth
that sells beer back to the episode
on to the next
on to the next thing this is
the news current events what the [ __ ] is
happening on earth right now
guys i need i told rosie i really need
to start paying attention to what
happens i don't care
but just so i can respond when people
ask me things
i didn't know that johnny depp and all
that stuff was in court not do you i
know you don't give a no even though i
heard about the shooting yeah the [ __ ] i
don't know what you're talking about i
have no idea what's happening i've just
been seeing memes of johnny depp in the
courtroom and i'm like okay
and then rosie told me like yeah he's
going through like a court case with his
girl like
huh
who yeah
johnny depp testifies about the girl
[ __ ] on his side of the bed
that's disgusting
oh because yeah he was oh i didn't know
what i didn't know the story is like is
he in trouble
i think he was on a recorded light or
some [ __ ] saying he wanted to kill her
rappers do that [ __ ] too all day you
heard eminem
but you know what i'm saying like i
don't know what's happening i don't know
current events or news i need to get
more on it so here's a couple current
events or news and it might be like old
to you but remember we filmed these
episodes like days in advance so here we
go the very first thing we're going to
be talking about and hopefully this
makes it better
obviously elon you guys know elon musk
is that [ __ ] bought twitter
all right the whole thing
do you understand what i just said he
bought a whole earth's connecting app
you're balling yeah you're bawling like
44 mil or a billion
i wonder how that negotiation went it's
like hex head like
the dude's gonna sell the the uh how
many billies does the dude need for the
cowboys it's however many he wants it's
like it's interesting that's how much
twitter is worth there is 44. i would
ask for a hundred yeah
but he bought twitter
whether or not this is a real picture i
saw i don't know because there's always
elon musk tweets you guys seen memes of
them and i'm like did elon must really
say that or someone photoshopped you on
my saying some wild [ __ ] but he
basically said freedom of speech should
be free and not censored
i'm very happy to hear that
i'm really excited also the earth's
about to get wild if [ __ ] can
say whatever they want and not get
deleted
we'll see hopefully elon musk likes weed
because i like twitter too
and percy likes weed he's the most
famous
the weed puff of all i mean he hit it
i mean in my mind he [ __ ] smokes
every day i hope i hope so
but anyway you almost bought twitter i
don't know what you guys think about
that leave it in the [ __ ]
comments but like i said we check up to
a thousand comments should you have
bought twitter or should he have solved
world hunger he could do both right now
with a
wire transfer
yo type in these nine rounding numbers
there you go
um
so i don't know i don't know what that
means i don't know to detect i know elon
musk
owns tesla
it's about as far as it goes for me
i know nothing more about the man
um but yeah that's pretty [ __ ] insane
that somebody bought twitter yeah and i
mean it's a good step for us i think
like just as far as people that like to
be able to post [ __ ] without being
[ __ ] uh censored yeah twitter's
pretty okay though tweet i'm allowed to
post stuff they don't really [ __ ] with
me too much i just [ __ ]
hit 50k on there finally i mean i've had
twitter for like five years
i just don't twitter's a different place
for me i don't really understand it that
way i don't know what subtweeting is i
hear that all the time i don't know what
that means i need to learn more since i
do social media for a living but i need
to learn more i got you but that's the
first thing is elon musk bought twitter
randomly for [ __ ] what i don't know
but cool at least just a person that you
could tie it to go that person's owns
twitter instagram it's just an entity
that deletes you
at least you get deleted on twitter you
go well [ __ ] that i'm returning my tesla
[ __ ] this lease you know like at least
you can go yeah yeah
[ __ ] my tesla this guy just deleted my
account or whatever it is i don't know
but
that's my little thing there it is
elon musk that's what i know about earth
right now that's when i know what's
going on
that's about flexing that [ __ ]
knowledge oh [ __ ] i read it on twitter
on one tweet on twitter about
[ __ ] buying it
and here we are here we go um but yeah
you know
people will always be in the comments
below you need to learn more like watch
another show [ __ ] i'm trying all
right this is what you get i'm trying
at least there's a will uh-huh we're
getting there
elon's gonna be on this [ __ ]
pretty soon one day for sure i know that
and i'm gonna go hey
i need you to inhale this
he's just gonna fart floating
yeah he's just so [ __ ] beam up he's
some alien he's just too smart for his
own good i know that
i watched some of his joe rogan [ __ ] and
the way he speaks i'm like are you a
human very very robotic but then but
very pers it's so precise it's like
huh you're like a freestyler that's like
go catch up the beat
catch up i'm ready for the next line
like yo you already know what you're
going to say before that man asks the
[ __ ]
it's so odd it's like computing it's
yeah he really is considering what he's
going to say and give you the most like
thoughtful answer he can at least that's
how it felt
yeah i think it's because he can't go
[ __ ] yeah he's being well
because that's me my huh
[ __ ] is my
hmm
he has to be so careful with everything
he says yeah yeah he does he does
but um that's that's some of the news
the other part of the news i hope you
guys have seen it i am for it
i don't feel that it was wrong and i am
so happy
that i told marty about it because
usually marty tells me about [ __ ]
the other day
i woke up got on my [ __ ]
twitter account and i saw mike tyson
beating someone's ass
not in a ring
that's a scary man
to be [ __ ] fighting outside of a
sanctioned fight
someone has to stop it that's willing to
stop him
you might die yeah i don't know how the
dudes lived so here we go
if you guys haven't if you haven't heard
about this
i watched i sent it to marty
this guy
they're on a plane correct it looks like
first class but yeah right three rows
down is some white dude
looking at the camera like
and some guy's talking you know the
commentary and he's recording his homie
like zooming in like look at this fool
talking to mike tyson mike tyson's on
our flight mike tyson's sitting in front
of the white guy so i'm the white dude
dude's over there filming he's like oh
hey what's up mike tyson
like looking back at the camera like
[ __ ] with him
i don't know what he said but all i
remember is that the last part of the
clip of him talking he goes [ __ ]
peasants
they're peasants that's all i hear him
say and the next clip is him getting
worked damn so i don't know what he said
but it looks like he's
he's invading the [ __ ] out of mike
tyson's space i need to know what he
really said because mike tyson like
we've talked about many times marty on
and off camera
is a different kind of guy right now
he's more at peace and chilling like
he'll let me be
and i will just let you be yeah and for
him to get mad enough to violently
outburst on a [ __ ] that had no
chance of defending himself
that guy deserves it yeah that guy
deserves it that was like a self-defense
it's a self-defense i mean
he could've just went hey i'm gonna hit
ya and he would have left
but i'm glad he unloaded on him yeah all
i saw was mike tyson hitting a speed bag
he wasn't even throwing full hip punches
or nothing just
yeah
[ __ ] what is it called uh
a touch-up he just touching this
[ __ ]
but the fool's just
but he looks back at the camera oh
that guy's drunk as [ __ ] that's not
drunk that's that trunks frat boy [ __ ]
look at this that's the look he was
giving like
you just made mike tyson mad as [ __ ]
enough to beat your [ __ ] ass for the
bam the dude like you're gonna put tyson
in this position because you want to be
[ __ ] cool on instagram 15 minutes of
being on instagram
so whoever you are man i know his dad
his dad got a call from his dad's friend
and he went
i know
you know they mean like you know his dad
or one of his family members is an avid
boxing fan and he's like do you see what
tyler did today he was beat up on a
plane by mike tyson you know he's the
shame of family right now you know that
i hope so that sucks for him because you
know that was a struggle
they were getting off the flight i think
or yeah i think they're getting off the
flight
they're just waiting for people to get
off or maybe getting on because there
wasn't a lot of people in the flight
last flight i was on the lady in front
of me was [ __ ] cursing out her man
next to her very aggressively
and they they almost booted that [ __ ]
off for yelling at him yes she was like
she was coming at this [ __ ] floor i
forget what it was over
he called her a [ __ ] or something and
she was just going in on him and going
and then the flight the people came over
like is everything okay here is no and
you know like i mean they were getting
ready to [ __ ] bring the [ __ ] feds
on for her i'm surprised they didn't
i'm surprised they didn't [ __ ] pile
on that dude and stomp them out as a
[ __ ]
aircraft unit yeah i mean that's what
they're supposed to do yeah he had multi
there was minutes of this [ __ ] going
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] to my time so mike
you got to be aware of mike tyson's on
your first class flight i mean the and
the guy's like it's [ __ ] mike dyson
oh my god look he's talking to mike
tyson
it was just seemed so odd it's like they
didn't care that he just got his ass
beat
yeah
it was just oh yeah he's lucky to be
like it's just a weird situation either
way
[ __ ] that guy
uh what does charlemagne do donkey is a
day man yeah this is art you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you oh marty
the rifle in the in the planes
sound effect
took him in the yeah
mike didn't do it mike didn't do it with
somebody else man
there's mass there's face swap
here we go
so anyway that was my current news
that's all i know elon musk spent a hell
of money and some guy i got beat up by
my dice and then damn that sucks no uh
air knuckles well we were pondering when
we first talked about this
is it possible for mike tyson in a fit
of rage
dumb and dumber style punch through
somebody's chest rip their heart out i
don't think so and in the most horrific
rage the dude just threw a bottle at
them i know i don't think he could break
the chest plate
youtube don't get mad this is a [ __ ]
conversation don't demonetize this this
is medical
this is medical this is a medicinal
conversation we need to know i don't
know i think you i don't think i don't
think so
i don't think so but i know he could
break it enough to where he could break
your chest plate and maybe pierce what
about with your own chest what about
five punches
five punches yeah he's in there yeah i
think so yeah he's in there
marty wants it to happen i gotta know
like will smith smack [ __ ] mike
tyson next time
i don't know but
i think maybe five
uh mike tyson's punch is the same pounds
per square inch as
mark mcguire's home run swing
okay now think of that and he was right
at all right mike tyson will punch you
as hard as mark maguire will hit you
with a bat
getting hit with a bad is [ __ ]
horrifying imagine getting hit with a
bat but it's someone's hand
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
um so that's the news
that's the news
look at that oh i look at my nose it
says punches guys story time what oh my
notes messed up story time
so here we go you know i'm gonna
save that one just for a sec i'll tell
that story here in a minute
this is a segment this is a new segment
called
what the [ __ ] i'm watching marty called
me just he goes we need to do a [ __ ]
semicolon
what the [ __ ] i'm watching right now
yeah there it is that's what's gonna be
called what the [ __ ] i'm watching
because why not all right this is
brought to you by [ __ ] us here we go
this segment is brought to you by us and
it's called what the [ __ ] i'm watching
are you ready guys it's gonna be movies
doesn't matter remember we used the
first couple episodes i did suggestions
of [ __ ] to watch now we just did it
called what the [ __ ] i'm watching so
here we go
first off
i've talked about it before
talking about it again i am still it's
one of the few shows i've ever watched
as it comes out by week and i hate doing
that [ __ ] i like to just watch the
season of something if i'm going to
watch it or no like i'll finish it
tomorrow i don't like waiting weeks but
i'll wait weeks and i have been in a
[ __ ] sex dick i've been watching
snowfall snowfall's such a good show
also pay rick ross for taking his
likeness
uh
snowfall is such a good [ __ ]
show i just started it too you did yeah
what episode you won like we just
watched episode one
you're hooked
i'm on season five episode nine oh i
didn't realize there was that many
[ __ ] seasons this guy'd be the last
one it's getting wild as [ __ ] you're on
season one i wish they could watch
season one first time again it's like
watching the wire have you seen the wire
yeah some of it oh that's just bomb
anyway
watching snow fall just throwing it out
there real quick i'm watching snowfall
they're doing a scene this [ __ ]
mansion
all right they're doing this in this
[ __ ] mansion spot
and i'm like i know that bedroom
i i'm active on zillow i am constantly
looking for the house that i can go
i'm gonna get that [ __ ] and i put it on
my screen saver cause i'm like that's
the house i lie i know it and that's
gonna be mine cool and when i get it and
move in i'm gonna change my screensaver
so here we go i'm watching snowfall and
there's a scene where in this ballrast
mansion and i'm like that is the house i
want that's on zillow
it goes to another scene in the house
like that's the [ __ ] house
goes to the front doorway and go that is
the double [ __ ] stairway coke dealer
[ __ ] from the 80s it's an 80s show about
coke dealers so i always call like this
my coke dealer 80s house that's what i
always call it and that's exactly what
they used it for then they're running
out of the house
and
as the image that they show is the image
on my screensaver and i told marty
because they know what they're doing
they're getting the best angles of that
house so if you're gonna film running
out the front let's get the best thing
all the [ __ ] house yeah it's the same
exact house as my screensaver i look to
that it's the same [ __ ] house
it is the same [ __ ] house guys
blew my mind rosie was asleep and i woke
rest up like wow they
anyway i just thought it was a trip so
what the [ __ ] i'm watching the snowfall
and those [ __ ] are in my house
all right i'm gonna get that [ __ ]
something's gonna happen
i'm gonna get that [ __ ]
i love that house anyway i thought that
was very cool that the house that's on
my screensaver is literally i'm watching
this [ __ ] it was very crazy
so on to the next part of what the [ __ ]
i'm watching this is something i had
already watched and i'm gonna talk about
it real quick i won't leave you any
spoiler [ __ ]
batman the new batman i watched that
[ __ ] marty
have you watched that [ __ ] yet
no i'm not all in the batman like that
i told you the last batman i mean you're
like michael keaton batman michael
keaton batman that's why oh yeah that's
pretty much where the good ones are for
me i love them yeah the dark knights and
all that they're [ __ ] sick when it
comes to batman and like fun and joker
and michael keaton that [ __ ] is the ones
that i like
penguins great the new ones are dark
night [ __ ] was badass different type of
batman yeah
this new batman
my personal opinion
is all right
kind of lukewarm okay
if i went off and smoked a bowl and came
back in the room i wouldn't care like
pause it
that's what i should say
oh my paws i'll be right back i'm gonna
smoke a bowl no i didn't do that i would
be like
that sounds like you let it go i'll be
right back it's long that's everything
though that's really the test of our
good
it was cool it was cool it's very
realistic detective style i know we've
just gotten to like a movie review right
now but i'm not gonna leave you anything
else
it wasn't very superhero-ish it was very
realistic like if batman was a real life
story
no superhero [ __ ] or crazy [ __ ]
crazy joker turning into joker because
he fell into some goo i love my batman
but the fact that he fell into some goo
and turned like white is just the
weirdest [ __ ] ever
anyway i [ __ ] love jack nicholson
here we go movie was okay from me to you
if you want to watch it go watch that
[ __ ] as long as [ __ ] it was all right
it's okay okay
all right on to the next thing on what
the [ __ ] i'm watching
i
just fell back in love with the ufc two
days ago
i don't know why i stopped like it's
i watched ufc ones and you guys already
know the story from blockbuster she ran
from blockbuster when they first came
out me and my dad we betting [ __ ]
coins and nickels and dimes on fights
i watched to like
just to where tito ortiz and chuck
liddell were really in their [ __ ]
three uh when when tito ortiz got
knocked out by chuckled with the hands
that's when i was like on my way out i
told marty the second i really started
selling weed heavy it was over i stopped
watching
sports in ufc because i'm not home on
those days to watch i'm selling drugs
and getting [ __ ] up so that's when my
life kind of changed 2007
eight is the last time i really watched
ufc until two days ago
just to put that in perspective for you
guys crazy a long long long time i've
missed i missed careers
i take it back i've seen a few anderson
civil fights that might have been after
might have been let's say 2009 10 is the
last time i watched ufc
still a while yeah khabib you've told me
about him i've never watched him fight
ever never seen a [ __ ] match never
seen him throw a punch until two days
ago and i watched the fight where he
fought that guy date gaith
white dude yep oh yeah
that could be guys scary [ __ ]
yeah
i don't know some scary [ __ ] way but
the way he was just walking up
it's not like he was getting into motion
he just walks up i'm gonna kick you in
the chest like yo that feels scary yeah
there's a silver was at least like
[ __ ] wasted yeah this fool doesn't
give a [ __ ] if you're gay
no the [ __ ]
yeah gagey's like that too no that guy's
a boxer that will knock [ __ ]
out i see that weird uppercut he was
throwing
and he [ __ ] that chandler guy up
that's when i'm like yo this is a good
ufc fight and i saw the next one like
yeah let me try kabib i've never seen
him i heard he's the [ __ ] man from
you yes yes whoa i am missing the [ __ ]
just the way you said you're jealous of
me not seeing snowfall i'm [ __ ]
jealous and fans let us know if you want
if you want to see this [ __ ] we think
you do
like yolo reacts to like
mcgregor's career never could be
mcgregor
i've just seen the box imagine him
before me with her because my friend had
it yes oh my god you missed so many
i'm high the fascinating yeah
i know this [ __ ] is tricky with the
different things i know i almost want to
hit that can
i haven't seen any of mcgregor's saying
that you haven't you could sit down and
watch his career up to this point yeah i
haven't seen him
nothing
nothing
anderson silva when he snapped his leg
on that cake
that's the snaps pretty it's pretty much
it yeah i saw ronda rousey fight her
first fight
dude i have missed every single major
fight in the past decade because i was
selling drugs and then i started doing
this
yup and you're aware of the whole like
controversy with mcgregor and khabib
fought all the beef they had and [ __ ]
and mcgregor like they're in the same
weight class yeah well they fought yeah
well he beat mcgregor's ass if he's 29-0
yeah okay but there was all this because
like mcgregor you'll notice mcgregor at
first everybody loved him because he was
the underdog he was eight mile he came
in he was rugged he was tough and he
just you know he was super confident but
he was the underdog and then he you know
chad mendes and then jose aldo and then
he had all these things although
yeah i stopped watching him when he was
young
but
at some point his ego became so big and
massive that it just kind of like
shifted
and then it's just this epic arch and
then he started taking all these losses
and uh he i got into ufc right around
them he fought chad mendes mcgregor was
getting his face
brutal elbows ground and pound me and
april were like oh my god oh [ __ ] the
fact that he just took it and then he
got back on his feet
big left hand puts him down like the
[ __ ] was heroic and then he drops jose
you know i'm sure you know all this like
the outcomes of these [ __ ] i've never
seen any of those all right i'm not
going to ruin all this that's what i
said you said jose aldo well he must be
in his late 30s now
i started watching that [ __ ] my
point
he
got into starting all these epic beefs
with everybody that he fought with i
missed all of this man i i'm ready i
haven't seen any one single fight of
what you're talking about but with
khabib you can't disrespect
people from different countries don't
take like you can't they're not gonna
go back and forth [ __ ] talking with you
oh you did that to him well he tried to
do it with khabib what he does with
everybody especially after that
mayweather fight that [ __ ] got corny as
[ __ ] they went on a world tour just like
roasting each other for the [ __ ]
fight
the [ __ ] got real corny real quick they
literally did like six cities on stage
just roasting each other to lead up to
the fight it really was like a [ __ ]
rap battle or some [ __ ] basically
but uh with khabib
you know he really disrespected could be
released could be felt he did that's why
after the fight and i'm sure you saw it
could be left over the [ __ ] fence and
double front kicked double
eagle jumped into the crowd onto
mcgregor's training partner ron artest
meleed the crowd yeah after he choked
out mcgregor never seen this
marty i don't watch anything all right
i'll just think this is french are all
drug dealers bro pop culture to me no
they don't do anything they don't watch
this [ __ ] you want full run art listen
we got to do this on twitch or some [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i've never seen any
none of my friends are into fighting let
me commentate the [ __ ] yeah you sell
drugs
yeah what
and by the way nate diaz nick diaz
please let's go i'll smoke you the [ __ ]
out and we'll talk about the 209
could you imagine
so i got back into ufc all right
we'll stop and we'll keep going with
that because
i'm excited oh
there are some fighters i've never even
heard their names like yo this guy is 15
and what holy [ __ ] this one's been
around
i've missed whole careers guys
so uh george st pierre matt hughes has
really went over damn soul throwback
when i was heavy heavy heavy that was
such a good battle that was the best
battle ever
matt hughes is such a good wrestler
excuse me george and pierre's such a
good striker and wrestler
he was just better than matthews that's
it no matter how much i wanted matt used
to win he just couldn't do it
george saint pierre was just so good
yeah school's one of the greatest of all
time he did take george st pierre once
though i think he like lately locked him
or something i remember i remember he he
lost and george saint peter wasn't even
beat up and i can see it on his face
like oh he's never going to lose again
like that that guy looks pissed
he's a jean-claude van damme but like
real
yeah there you go you got that yeah
george appears man
here we go i got a good uh watch for you
what what the [ __ ] i watched what
what are you watching i know i don't
watch a lot of things
uh all right sport i'm gonna i'm gonna
try to not spoil this but i will give
you the premise of this movie on hulu
called fresh
he told me i know like the word fresh is
such a nice nasty sound you say fresh
like
it's nasty in this [ __ ] movie so
here's the premise of this movie all
right you got a regular dude 35 year old
white dude all right medtech
and he's
taking
he's you know out me
picking girls up at the grocery store so
he picks a girl up at the grocery store
they start dating he's casually dating a
little bit invites her on a light
vacation
takes her up you know on a little
weekend getaway vacation you can't tell
me no more
you're going to give me the whole movie
i'm just getting to the premise okay
it's just a premise this is a movie
okay okay so how many drone shots do
they have of the car driving there's a
couple there's you know this you know
i'm not gonna sit here and say that the
[ __ ] was shot amazingly it was okay
all right this is [ __ ] you would
probably see on a trailer all right
okay
all right
that face oh this is gonna be disgusting
go ahead i'm
so he ends up
he ends up drugging this girl okay
so
the girl's in a hostage situation this
is [ __ ] you would see on the trailer
okay she ends up being in a hospital but
this isn't a regular human trafficking
style situation that she's got caught up
in
all right this fool is a med tech
who's a part of a society
of
cannibals disgusting
but dude for the freshness of the meat
he keeps the people alive
as long as possible
but his take like takes pieces off of
them
and is like packaging it should be [ __ ]
and like
it'll make you be vegetarian guys you
guys feel like wanting to be a [ __ ]
vegan go ahead and watch fresh on hulu
i don't like that kind of stuff it was
horrifying but what i liked about it it
was so over the top that it was funny
this thing is that's not even over the
top i know it's not i'm like i'm like
listen thomas watches this he's gonna
tell you how this [ __ ] really goes on
all the time like yeah underworld of
societies of elite rich people that eat
people and show that and people that
just do that to people because they're
[ __ ] psychotic yeah
dude
you know they find more chopped up
bodies than than not
that means like we don't even know if it
was alive when it happened how would you
be missing how long has this person been
gone five years damn they just found
everybody they've been alive this whole
time
people are [ __ ] creeps bro that's why
i have such a weird
i can't sit with my back to anything i
have to sit too i
even though no one's out like
i'm not i know you're being too like all
right well then you don't and then if
you get [ __ ] snatched up what are you
gonna say i'm gonna text thomas when i
get out of this you're not getting out
of this [ __ ] that's why i'm very
cautious
i just i'm so cautious too because
[ __ ] are weird anywhere even
this nice ass hotel in napa yo i search
everything anywhere i go to make sure
can someone get in this i just move
mirrors change [ __ ] like
this a wall is this gonna be a [ __ ]
way someone could sneak in in the night
and [ __ ] kill me or kidnap somebody
[ __ ] happens all the [ __ ] time
it's so weird that it does and no one's
like scared of it
bro i'm gonna kill you if you try to
[ __ ] do some [ __ ]
i'm heavy i will bite through your chest
i'll [ __ ] eat your face off if i have
to you're not taking me
but people do get taken your dad ate a
guy's face right dad bit the guy's
cheeks off because he thought some [ __ ]
was going down like that that's what i'm
saying like i'll [ __ ] do it too now i
get why he was thinking that when i was
a kid like why would you do that
now i get it like i will [ __ ] oh
it's so scary like the things i will do
to you if you try to do some wild [ __ ]
to me or rosie it's like i'm a nice dude
and i will
you know how many times i thought about
it like i don't like fighting i hate it
but there's been times where i'm like
dude if i'm if i fight this guy right
now
i'm gonna bust his arm in half because
my thing is like
you're gonna wake up from this knockout
with a snapped leg
i'm gonna hold it and i'm gonna kick
your [ __ ] knee straight in
and snap that [ __ ] back so when you
wake up
that's what you have to remember for the
rest of your life that you can't walk
right ever again
and you have like 200 000 surgery coming
to you
like i said i feel so evil thinking
about that
but i'm just like i know i [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
swim through you uh i'll rip it open i'm
like
like you said how many punches five i'm
gonna i can do the
the watermelon thing
yeah there was a [ __ ] certain hate
that disgusting celebrities that get
outed for [ __ ] talk you know trying
to talk to underage girls and [ __ ] and i
consider
you know what i mean what level of
security it would take to [ __ ] stop
me from coming to see you if you did
that [ __ ] to my daughter
i think
cause look this is what this is the way
i see
i'll just pay somebody
don't go to prison this place i'm gonna
go do it
i don't know i'm not done
i'm just saying if that situation never
arose
anyway sorry we got all violent right
now but that's what i think about all
the time [ __ ] that movie fresh
i don't trust no one i don't trust
anybody
ever
[ __ ] that and you shouldn't that's the
[ __ ] up no you might turn around in
this really nice
hotel turn around the ladies got to show
gunpoint like yo things happen people
are [ __ ] weird just be cautious
that's why i like to let it know be
known where i'm at but if some [ __ ] goes
down you know where the [ __ ] i was
you know and i'm gonna be dead weight
i'm not helping these [ __ ]
carry me at all i'm gonna [ __ ] follow
the ground i'm gonna do all that type of
[ __ ] dude
oh you know
against the walls all that [ __ ] you
better be strong
no yeah people can have big
[ __ ] too so i'm not saying i'm
untouchable i'm saying
i hope it never nothing ever happens but
because i'm so nice but if i want to be
a dick it's like dude that i hate could
you imagine feeling like that all the
time
like yeah i'm gonna kill that fool
ew
that's such a nasty feeling to have in
your body
like no i'm gonna end it i'm gonna kill
him
that's sad
i don't know why it just makes me like
oh i would hate to go to sleep with that
feeling like yeah i'm gonna kill him
or just anybody or just be willing to
just be like be on such edge at all
times that you're willing to be like
that towards anybody that's sad yeah
i don't like that feeling that's why i
don't even think about i don't watch
movies like that cause i start thinking
about that [ __ ] yeah
like movies like that scare the [ __ ] out
of me because people are so weird and
creepy bro yes
yeah
that [ __ ] is real should have posted
this i'm going to be with this medical
tech all weekend this is the [ __ ]
yeah come on we got to be more careful
that was part of the movie people got to
be more careful dude
for real
especially with even just your [ __ ]
homies like like if you're just in your
where you grew up and you're in some
hood and you got just your other [ __ ]
hood homies around and you guys are all
wrapped up in each other's business and
there's girls and [ __ ] like i've heard
of so many stories of drugs money little
little tiny bits of money little 40 30
50
bits of [ __ ] money
or even no money or even they just
they just might want to turn on you
because they're better friends with
these dudes over here and he wants to
look cool to him
been there
oh that's a whole different type of hood
uh-huh
this one mexican ones are different it's
not like it's not it's not as
i feel like
i don't know what it is like the mexican
gang banger culture is so different it's
more like you have to be like did you
get an okay to kill this guy
that's how i feel that those guys are
it's scary
i don't like anybody hurting anybody but
i feel like
i mean drive-bys happen everywhere man
it's just like the level of gangs
like you don't see mechs and mafia dudes
like yo another drive-by maximum mafia
today like you know you don't see that
[ __ ] you never find those [ __ ] guys
bodies they just go where did they go
you know what i'm saying like it's
different levels of gangs like weird
[ __ ]
there's some like i'm sure there's like
mafias and stuff in south central you
know like fools that are in suits like
no we kill everybody like oh god please
leave me alone that's why it's not good
to yell people in traffic because the
nice dude looking dude in traffic or in
the prius
might be a [ __ ] real deal drug deal
that drives a prius because he doesn't
want to be seen and he kills your ass
be safe dude
you ever get on a page on instagram and
go how is this left up this is a loud
but not my weed this guy got shot in the
head i know i found one of those threads
the other day and i don't like seeing
that [ __ ] but one of them caught my
attention so much these dudes are in
traffic
one guy cuts off a guy and stops him
dude gets out with a bat
and smacks the guy's [ __ ] car
the guy opens his door and he goes to
hit the dude
and he misses and the dude gets out in
like a striped shirt regular pants
shoots the dude like six times
the dude's running away with the bat
falls and the guy walks up does this
dumps the whole thing
walks back in his car and drives off
like it was nothing
square banker looking dude like a
[ __ ] square mexican dude looked like
me but like a regular dude in a suit
like a slick tear
but the way he shot him was like yo you
were waiting for a [ __ ] to come
up on you like that
you opened the door so he could swing at
you once he swings that the thing is the
guy falls and he just walks up the guy's
laying down almost dead and then just
keeps going it's like you're not getting
out of that well of course go to prison
forever yeah but you never know that guy
could be from another country go i'm
leaving today anyway i'll give a [ __ ]
about you uh-huh a lot of the time the
gang [ __ ] they just leave a country
i don't know how we got into that
because of fresh yes
god see i don't like this horrible vibe
we never even talked about [ __ ] like
this i don't like it
i'm watching snowfall
[ __ ] i'm watching people cringing
what else can we let's get off this
horrible topic i can actually feel like
the tension in my body talking about
that nasty [ __ ]
sorry guys
my bad what are we at i'm gonna say 131.
120. ah okay i was way off
here we go so that was what the [ __ ] i'm
watching
what the [ __ ] am i what the [ __ ] am i
watching
that should be it that should be every
time it's different like that's what the
[ __ ] i'm watching what the [ __ ] am i
watching like today i was on some weird
[ __ ] so this is what uh there we go i
like that
guys this next story
is another all right sorry here we go
this is a story time i should say this
story takes place in april
uh for remember i just told you about
the story about the wedding so now let's
go to the bachelor party which happened
in early april
wedding was last weekend or this past
couple days
so let me tell you about vegas and my
very first bachelor party experience
ever never been to a bachelor party
just never have okay
ever this was right after the rookie
williams episode right
filmed the ricky williams episode got in
the rental
drove to vegas
so here we go ready
never met any single one of these people
except the groom
never met any of them none of these guys
but now we're at the wedding you know a
couple days ago we all know each other
it was cool we were chilling
this is me meeting these people never
met the guys we're standing at airbnb
never met him nothing
so i get there at like
10 o'clock at night because i was
filming the ricky williams episode and
i'm not going to miss that [ __ ]
so i drive off
rosie's not with me this is one of the
reasons i do not like
i don't want to go to a strip club by
myself or with my friends that sounds
weird and terrible
but if i go with rosie it's [ __ ]
awesome it's cool as [ __ ] way cooler all
right trust me
if you have a girlfriend and she likes
straight ups go with a girl strippers
are like oh i don't feel threatened
this is going to be cooler like yeah
it's just way cool over here
so i'm going with a group of dudes the
last time i went to a strip club with
dudes was right a week after i turned 21
and i went for the first time to vegas
here we go i get to the house
everyone's chilling my homie mundo groom
shows me up to my room and i'm like he's
like you're sharing a room my cousins go
what did you just say
i have to share a room we all paid for a
house
i'm like it's your wedding i'm not gonna
say anything i'm just gonna tough it out
i go in like this is the biggest room
i've ever seen me and this floor 30 feet
apart in a different bed like oh okay
who gives a [ __ ]
you could have fit a gym in this room
it's this big he's bigger than twice the
size of this room aren't you so i'm like
okay there's just two beds in the
dresser in here that's fine
so i put my stuff
down and
on each person's bed shout out to alex
the best man he put like the hangover
pills and a bunch of liquid ivs marty
damn yeah and everyone's bad like a
hotel all separated the same way
like it was pretty [ __ ] cool it was
cool i'm like dancing
all right so we get downstairs i get
dressed or whatever we're chilling
we go to
a hookah lounge i've never been to a
hookah because i hate hookahs they make
my head feel sick i feel sick from the
tobacco smoke i smoked them before my
homies in like high school not for me
the smell of it not so bad anyway go to
hookah lounge did you know [ __ ]
go there to chill did you know there's
it's like a little nightclub market
people are hanging out
drinking and dancing
and hitting the hookah
it's like yo this is weird weird no way
i'm always in lackawanna my arabian like
muslim home did i saw i was put on the
hookahs back they used to really do the
hookah [ __ ]
i don't know if there's if it's kind of
different now this is more
commercialized
they had the kohl's and tinfoil but okay
they didn't have the wet the wet buried
this the yeah
my uh middle easter homie merced that's
how i and my mexican friend that's how i
first started smoking hookah with them i
just did it because like oh we're
smoking i'm 15. [ __ ] it you know what
i'm like this is nasty and then i just
started throwing wheat in the top the
hookah was a big giant homer simpson
head doing this
and the hookah came out top and that was
the coolest thing ever so we figured out
how to put weed in it in a bowl without
the coal we just roasted it we thought
it was good
four hoses uh-huh
so we could all smoke out of his head i
was so sick anyway
get to the hook lounge like [ __ ] for
real this is crazy people chill here
and
oh so we're with the raider dude so it's
very very easy to get into anywhere
when you're with the star running back
of the team in the town that you're in
the stadium is [ __ ] eight blocks away
like they're like
come right in like no way
that's crazy that's a lot you're like of
course yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] just like not the
hook line you have to get a reservation
but i'll tell you about more like we
went to nightclubs and [ __ ] anyway i was
like that's right you know all the spots
you live here
take us so we let him like show us where
we're gonna go how we're gonna do this
so it's cool right
so i'm sitting there and i just go
outside within five minutes and start
smoking [ __ ] joints and i come back
in we're drinking we're drinking it's
cool i'm like you know what i'm not
driving i'm just gonna drink [ __ ] it
so we go after that we're like all right
we're going to a strip club and it had
just opened seven
six days before we got there
brand new i mean hygienic nice right so
i'm like oh brand new no babies born in
here and [ __ ]
sick
i don't know if that's real but i'm just
saying like it was pretty hygienic
um so we get there
and i'm already a little tipsy
i get in there
and the last time i went to a strip club
when i was 21 with my friends
the whole trip i had four hundred
dollars and i made that [ __ ]
work for me
i hate daddies like seven times in those
three days with my homies so i could
spend this little amount of money as
possible and get [ __ ] up i was at the
slots like you know i'll take a slot oh
can i have a drink thank you i'll take a
double and i'll walk away after i get
that [ __ ] like i don't want to play
this here's a tip i just like i just got
like a 40 drink for three dollars sick
i was [ __ ] 21 but this time i go i'm
like oh i'm an adult now like yo can i
get all these ones can i get this much
i'm like this is going to be cool all
right but it's weird because i'm not
with rosie so i'm with my friend i'm
like [ __ ] it he says broom his bachelor
party will [ __ ] throw him on it's
whatever but we get a [ __ ] booth like
the dope booths at the strip club
because it's our friend's badge probably
like wall just throwing a [ __ ] butt
shit's expensive
getting booths at nightclubs and strip
clubs is racks
and i'm thinking it's it's spoiling [ __ ]
it let's just do it i'll buy it he goes
no we'll split and go oh okay you guys
want to split i'm like you i thought i'd
have to pay for this [ __ ] like no i'll
split it i didn't think that because
they're not going to pitch in i just
thought that cause you'll get this one
i'll get this one like i'm gonna spend
three bands just sit in a straight
oh no anyway it doesn't matter i was
just thinking like rosie's not even here
it's not gonna be fun
it's not fun
but it was cool anyway i'm sitting there
uh we're at a strip club obviously and
the reason i'm bringing this up is
because the most random [ __ ] you will
ever [ __ ] hear in your life
oh [ __ ] are you ready
you're gonna slam some heroin for those
no heroin don't hear ron you ready for
this one
this is actually completely empty on the
way
i got one drip in that [ __ ] it went
down went through my sweater hole it's
all the way in my stomach
oh all sticky
i was like there's one drop left can i
[ __ ] do that
[ __ ] you
[ __ ]
you ready no so
go to the bathroom of this place
so by the way i'm just doing this
throwing my friend there's like
strippers in my eye here
i'm just sitting back down on my phone
i hate me and i call this strip club
[ __ ] hate it but it's like i'm trying
not to be a dick like like uh
i'm just chilling but it's cool strip
clubs are fun because they're strip
clubs who gives a [ __ ] even if rosie's
not there i'm like oh cool here
i hate when people try to be like
are you not having a good time or like
try to like get you to drink i am the
master of oh no thank you later
that [ __ ] but underneath that is a
little bit of rage
a little bit of rage
why
just because it's like i'm not going to
act different because i'm here you want
me to start jumping up and [ __ ] down
like i'm here i'm me it's not that long
like i'm being weird just because i'm
not all [ __ ] hyper to be here yeah
okay
i got you
yeah the master that [ __ ] hi
hi i'm just waiting on my friends
wanna sit yeah go ahead
get away from me i don't want you next
to me
you can tell go look at that guy he's
[ __ ] shit-faced we'll talk to him
by i mean when rosie's not with me
because it's not like hey we should hang
out like no [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] engaged
i'm cool get away from me [ __ ] but if
you're really like yeah we should have
i'm like whoa [ __ ] cool that's fun
but i can't any other way i'm like no
i'm no no leave me alone so it was kind
of like an off feeling at a strip club
first time i've been to a strip club
since i was 21 without rosie so it was
just very weird
this is not the weird part it's not the
random sorry here we go here we go here
we go sorry
i go to the bathroom we have a booth
table i know how many people are with us
there are strippers
i know many dudes are with us
i know what they look like i've been
with them all night
go to the bathroom i come out
i wipe my hands i put it down open the
street club
playing some [ __ ] song all right get
away from me all right cool thank you a
move and that's me getting through a
strip club right thanks excuse me
and i walk and i get back to our booth
and like who is that
who's this man with our bottle
we got hella bottles and shows our
[ __ ] friend's bachelor party
and i'm like who's this
random man
his face looks so familiar
why do i know your [ __ ] face
and i'm talking to my homie moon and i
go dude
who is this guy
i don't know marty should i say it's an
actor but should i say
i'm not going to guess who it is no no
i'm saying like
it's not like i'm out he wasn't doing
anything weird he's just standing at a
strip club i don't know if he's like
guys married he's gonna get in trouble
with me saying i don't know i don't know
the rules i'll just say he wasn't being
a creep he's just standing there
talking to us
but
i'm like who is this giant buff man but
i know your face
and i look at my holy moon he goes you
recognize him i go i do why do i know
but i'm like i do
why do i know it i'm it's loud so he's
four feet can't hear me screaming like
yeah why why does he look so he's like
yeah that's yeah yeah from the sand
that is yeah yeah from the sand lot
huh
he's buff
he's really buff why and i'm like wait
no that's him
now then i introduced myself i'm like oh
well
i'm like
that is yeah yeah from the sand like
because i know squint's chauncey very
well like i know that man
and i'm like dude i just saw squids like
two days before there's like what are
the odds that
what
i just thought it was really weird guys
i'm at a strip club with my friends i
come back to our table and the fool from
the sandlot is just like what's up man
wait
what is happening
why are you here why are you so big
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah hot dog oscar mario even
and i just like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i'm just like dude
why is this [ __ ] here what are
the odds i come back from peeing
gone two minutes come back and where i
was at we're like who's this buff ass
dude and i'm when i mean buff he's as
big as this table
i don't know why he got huge
anyway
we were still there it was like i don't
know when we got there
half the people left and i'm with the
groom with a couple people left and you
know
it's getting like desolate and kind of
depressing when you're one of the few
people left at the strip club
that's when you're like oh reevaluate
your life bro
start thinking about what you're doing
it's it's time to go
so there's like eight dudes left in this
big strip club and us three oh my god
you guys ready to go i'm like i don't
want to cash any more money oh by the
way don't use atms at strip clubs sorry
i forgot to tell you that you guys know
i've said this before it's 30 for every
100 you take out 100 they actually take
out 130 and it says it but you're at a
strip club drunk you're not going to
leave to go to the bank
they know that
but this place is only 20 so every 100
you take out takes 120. i swiped my card
because i took out 500 bucks
before we got there i swiped my card
because i needed more money
and it said error pin error i got my
card in the mail the day before the day
i left so i'm like no it's activated but
it is a brand new card and i'm in a new
stage might look bad
i swiped that bit i tried like seven
[ __ ] times to take out 200 bucks
failed every time told roshan hey uh can
you cash out one of our friends here
because he's gonna give me the money so
yeah here i'm like oh problem solved
right
that wasn't throughout the time
now go back to where it's just us
hanging out it's like three dudes left
and i'm like all right cool let's leave
we walk we hit the corner past the
curtain
and that sun is up
that curtain's there to let you know to
not let you know that there's sunlight
up
and that you have been there throughout
the whole day changing
now the sun's up
you got there at night
how much money you spend you have no
idea because you're chilling
that's a strip club trap
anyway
we walk out like oh no
son
[ __ ] this is not good i know it's not a
good morning when i leave a strip club
with their son
not good
walk out
get an uber back to our spot i'm not
even drunk anymore because i was just
sitting around waiting for everybody to
like to be like we paid a lot for the
booth we weren't just trying to leave in
two hours you know what i'm saying so
we're just kind of sitting there even
though we didn't want to be there
anymore like uh
oh wait they're doing their thing over
there we'll just wait for them and we're
in a group so i'm not trying to leave
any fools i'm like wait where's
so-and-so he's left he got robbed i
don't know
so we leave get back to the house the
airbnb like we have to get food and the
only thing opens ihop i don't care
drove to ihop four dudes
reeking like alcohol i i stopped
drinking hours before i don't drink and
drive but i was smoking it the [ __ ] up
get to ihop i'm like it's 702.
this is gross you have glitter on you
all right let's go and i huh i hope
there's no kids i walk in they sit us
next to the only people in the
restaurant which is a father and his
three four-year-old daughter
i look over and i whisper
hey
i'm sleep deprived as [ __ ] i just drove
from la to right and the night i'm still
awake i'm like hey
i'm gonna say some fat last [ __ ] i
already know it
we shouldn't sit we shouldn't sit by
this little girl
and yeah there's a piece of wood between
us but you know it goes on i'm like yo
let me get a [ __ ] orange juice i get
him like oh
it's old no thank you i'm like [ __ ]
let me just get a pepsi and i get him
like
there's no syrup in this pepsi it's just
[ __ ] pepsi water and then i get my
pancakes i'm like oh these [ __ ]
are disgusting so anyway everything i
ate maybe i was just [ __ ] up hungover
or whatever
that's how the night morning ish ended
we get to back i stay up to like 10 in
the morning we have to go high-speed
go-kart racing because alex is the man
the best man set up a bunch of cool [ __ ]
we have to go at one so i'm like i'll
get up at 11. i slept for one hour
got up
did it again go-kart racing super fun
one of the girls who works at the
go-kart places was one of the strippers
at the place the night before marty and
i thought that was hilarious we all look
to go that's that girl from last night
no way she's tired she's had her next
job already holy [ __ ] i slept for an
hour she didn't
[ __ ] it okay
um
do the go-kart racing super cool should
be fun right
uh go throughout the night then we go to
the nightclub it's called drea or drea
or some [ __ ] that's a long ass story my
bad anyway we go it's meek mill has a
residency
you know residency where they like play
every night or every certain night you
can always go watch them
um so meek mill started it that night so
we got a table
one thing i suggest
if you're not a nightclub person you
don't like that kind of stuff do not buy
a table
my friend they they liked it but nobody
was like we could do the same thing
eight feet that way for five bands less
you know what i'm saying it's so [ __ ]
silly so expensive i think like i've
thought that in those lines before like
any other time of the day this is
[ __ ] free to be here
but right when i'm walking up it says
any marijuana snuck in you'll be
prosecuted at the highest extent blah
blah do not bring anything into the club
and i went bro there's like [ __ ]
joints in my hand in my pocket
and i'm thinking i'm two feet from the
[ __ ] guy i'm like dude are you
[ __ ] serious he's gonna feel this
he's gonna [ __ ] feel this and i just
put him
in my because i had to wear a [ __ ]
button i'm going to nightclub i'd put
all the joints in here and i just put my
phone in the front
and left it like that so he would be
like oh it's just your phone like this
is my phone and he didn't even [ __ ]
touch it and i just went oh bro am i
gonna get arrested i thought it was cool
here but they said that's like their
rules on their casino [ __ ] like you will
be prosecuted if you try to sneak [ __ ]
anyway
go
to get into these nightclubs on the top
of the roof every single person that i
can pass to take the elevators marty you
know what the kind of weight that is at
the end
dumbest [ __ ] ever get there i'm drinking
it's fun whatever
uh one of our friends bribes our
security guard he lets us [ __ ] hotbox
our cabana and we're just smoking the
cabana the [ __ ] out all night i'm like
dude now perfect yes meek mill's playing
i'm still smoking weed and i go out like
oh yeah i'm here for the concert i love
a [ __ ] cabana i'll chill it was cool
it was cool we can close it off we had
like a little pool area like our
personal spot or whatever it was cool i
don't care
i could have done i could have sat right
there for [ __ ] for free but they want
you to [ __ ] feel cool is all it is
yeah i didn't feel cool but i saw the
[ __ ] in the booth and i'm like
oh you guys feel cool take your pictures
with those bottles live it up
live it up i feel so douchey like me
[ __ ] too
unless i'm celebrating some dope [ __ ]
which is the bachelor party i get it
but none of us are like
nobody right we're chilling
and uh i'm looking at everybody else
like
wow nightclubs really really make money
huh
not off me but you guys really make
money i would never come back
but it was it was cool or whatever uh so
we're leaving and what happens guys
every single person has to use these
five six elevators
there's
400 people
elevated rides
i'm drunk as [ __ ] i will admit i drank
so [ __ ] everybody knows
no we had like we probably went through
like five bottles full [ __ ] fists of
just us like five six dudes we were [ __ ]
faced and they're smart they take the
bottle top and they don't leave it so
you can't take the bottle with you
nope
they tax you damn a bottle that's 80
will cost you 400
at a place like that
so you know what i did marty [ __ ]
baller
i put the entire bottle of tequila in my
pocket
in my pocket i don't know how i i must
have riches rip the stitchings a little
bit in my pants
i put the bottle in there i put my shirt
over my [ __ ] bottle and it stuck my
thumb straight into the top
i'm like oh i ain't spilling this [ __ ]
and i [ __ ] have it
i say i'm not waiting for this elevators
all my homies
we all took the stairs
that's what i would do industrial stairs
i don't know
huge flights of stairs i don't know what
we're on we're above caesar's palace so
whatever [ __ ] floor that is
we're we're above vegas we can see and
we take
i start hitting the stairs and the panic
of me did not slow down to [ __ ] hold
up the hundreds of people because we
were the first like six or seven people
to find the door and then as soon as we
opened the door i looked back and
everyone's rushing that was looking
waiting for the elevator they look and
like boom and cut so i was like dude
don't hold this up there's so
many people behind you you know what i
mean like i have to keep a pace
and i have this bottle and i'm just
holding each rail trying not to fall
down you know when you're drunk and
you're hitting the stairs and you just
wrap your body against the [ __ ] rail
i'm sliding to the next one i'm sliding
to the next round and i'm sliding around
and i'm just thinking don't fall because
you will get trampled there was that
many people marrying like if i fall i
got to get up quick and if i fall i
might stab myself with this bottle in my
pocket
so i'm just trying to make it out i'm
trying to make it out my homies are
right next to him like yo is this really
working
and we got it it took about 10 minutes
to get down the flight that's how many
stairs and we were almost jog running
fast fast fast to get down and we're
drunk as [ __ ] like we're not really like
that careful we're just flying down the
stairs sloppily just slopping down the
stairs sloppily
bad we get down the stairs and boom
we're all like oh [ __ ]
we're at the front of the [ __ ] casino
and we get out and i'm just like ah
i got this full [ __ ] fifth
and everybody's like you really stole my
you think i'm gonna let them keep that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that please yeah there we go
what that [ __ ] was [ __ ] you that's what
i don't care anyway
i take that ball to a strip club we go
to another strip club terrible place
we go in there i'm like i don't wanna i
don't know the vibes here are weird it
was a weird vibe i'm glad i'm not the
only person that thinks that it was a
weird the first place was cool the night
before remember i've only slept an hour
since i did the ricky williams episode
and it is now saturday night
that's like almost two days right
let's let that one hour everybody else
left like maybe 45 to an hour or two
so we're [ __ ] done right i'm at the
strip club and then our friend orders a
bunch of food there because we haven't
eaten yet
and then
just like my other strip club story
marty these strippers just start eating
all the wings
and fries
and i'm looking at my friend listen to
me like
yo they're just aren't they working
this is our [ __ ] like it's our table
over here this trip is eating our
i wasn't eating the wings but
i just remember thinking my friend looks
at me like
i'm standing i don't i don't wanna i'm
good i don't wanna be i'm just gonna
wait this one out i don't know why i
just don't feel this place it's weird
nobody's friendly it's kind of odd i'm
just going to tough this one out
oh sorry
rosie texts me
every transaction i did at that strip
club the night before went through
and they said i got my money
twenty two hundred dollars they said i
took out that i never even got because i
said error error error oh i told rosie
tell them to look at the [ __ ]
camera that they have in every atm and
watch me do this what the [ __ ] after
every time and watch them not see me
take any money from anything and they
looked at this [ __ ] they go okay yeah he
didn't get anything and they gave me all
my money back yeah thank god for these
atm cameras man i'm just gonna say like
good [ __ ] okay that's awesome um so back
to the night i'm sitting there one of
our friends is so [ __ ] shit-faced
drunk this one stripper just comes up to
him and will not leave him alone
and there's this point where he's
talking and he looks at us like
oh like what do you want me to do tell
her to leave dude he ended up giving her
a hundred dollars and please you just
gotta leave me alone
bro is she trying to pitch a lot lap
dance to him or something yeah the whole
time like
we bought the table we have all these
buttons she's like oh what does this guy
[ __ ] do
to that dude he was just like that
and then when he was uh getting a drink
she followed him and we're like and it
became on like a grunting joke like is
she gonna do it boom he goes to the
bathroom she waits for him outside the
bathroom like damn you think you're
gonna like marry this man
and he's just like what do i say what do
i say
and then she looks
he's that guy and we're our friends like
two of our other people are with us
we're like i don't want to be here
either
way this place is kind of odd like it is
right and we're looking at him just
[ __ ] dying because he can't get rid
of this girl and then i don't know where
she just like runs off from him yeah and
he comes back he goes
i just care like 100 and said please
leave me the [ __ ] alone
and he's like i felt so bad but it was
like two hours
he was with that girl damn and she was
just she's buying her drinks and she's
like well i'm gonna get a drink i'm
feeling rude not getting her a drink i'm
like dude we have bottles like i don't
want to rub my bottles
fair enough
fair enough all this money these
strippers should be just like one of
these strippers filled up an entire
[ __ ] red cup of our liquor i went
don't let that [ __ ] back over here she
saw one of our i just
kept going like [ __ ] that's not that's
a cup of liquor you scandalous [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you do what you're doing anyway um we
leave that place
we go back to the house
i sleep for about an hour and 45.
so now it's the whole weekend i've slept
three hours since well the thursday
night
saturday um
i drive back
that was it at the wedding the guy that
was [ __ ] faced drunk
with that stripper stayed
the one that got rid of her because he's
found the stripper he really was like oh
she's awesome okay we're leaving he's
like i'll be good
he calls us 40 minutes late he goes she
passed down this girl's drunk as [ __ ]
i'm trying to get my [ __ ] uber to get
to my car i'm like don't drive
and say i'll be fine don't worry didn't
hear from him again saw him at the
wedding
walks up i'm like
what happened he goes i'm gonna tell you
guys i blacked out at the nightclub i go
what do you mean he goes what did we do
after the nightclub but you don't
remember going to the [ __ ] strip club
he goes bro i i woke up home in my
driveway are you [ __ ] kidding me
he was so coherent and talking to us all
night he was completely blackout drunk
bro wow i had no idea that he was that
[ __ ] gone and he's like that's the
first time i've ever blacked out in my
life i'm about to be 40 years old
jesus christ i found it at the wedding
he told us and we told him everything
that happened he goes what do you mean
it's like that girl so what girl go
stripper you called us and said she
passed out he goes i called you what
strip club would go do
did you get drugged did you get [ __ ]
dressed you don't remember
you drove your car you were coherent
anyway
that was the whole vegas trip i just
thought i'd talk about that a little bit
because it was really [ __ ] hilarious
it
it was fun
i ate the same veggie place like three
times in a [ __ ] row it was bomb shout
out to veggie street
in vegas that [ __ ] was bomb as [ __ ]
um
that's it that's it marty all right that
was vegas and i drove my ass back caught
three hours of traffic as a [ __ ]
accident
and that was it all right and then fast
forward boom the pants debacle
hey
you're a good friend [ __ ] that [ __ ]
sucked i can't believe it anyway that
was vegas uh randomly people i watched
my whole life were just sitting at our
booth
yeah yeah yeah yeah no bendy the jet
rodriguez showed up and he's right
behind the jet rodriguez is a [ __ ]
active firefighter in l.a county
i'm waiting till the day i pull up and
see the firefighter go that is bendy the
jet rodriguez holy [ __ ] [ __ ] did he
tell you that
what did yeah yeah or somebody [ __ ]
no i just know that i just love this
anime i've looked all these fools up but
i just didn't know he was above uh i
love this talent dude i've looked around
what are they supposed that was years
ago though but yeah benny jerry is a
[ __ ] firefighter in la county okay
it looks like you think
he doesn't look like the baseball
version of him at the end at all
at all
not even [ __ ] close mustangs nothing
nothing um marty wow that was like a
half an hour story i'm very sorry we had
two hours yet
about 157 yeah 150ish
okay
what the [ __ ] oh it's your chair yeah
let's get the [ __ ] out of me dude no i
didn't just [ __ ] my pants
i feel really bad
i wouldn't i would cut it i would get it
what's the next thing on the soundboard
okay there's marty [ __ ] he just
and he vid how to record yourself at
home
yo marty did a video called how to keep
your girl on his youtube
so [ __ ] smart i'm gonna say smart oh
i think it's smart as [ __ ] you know how
many [ __ ] people out here everything
you say is just common sense you know
that right
i don't know that no things that you
should do as a [ __ ] person
to the person that you're with yeah
you took me a lot of years i felt like i
was given like experience i'm saying
there's a lot of people out there that
if you're a dude
and you know your girlfriend wants to
hang out you're playing games for like
four hours straight
you are [ __ ] up yeah because if she
loved watching a certain show and you're
like yo let's chill wait hold on let me
just watch this show for four hours
like
[ __ ]
imagine that
it's the same feeling uh-huh
the same [ __ ] feeling
i'm gonna say there's that common sense
marty yeah
is not even in most people's vocabulary
okay so just listen to marty's video all
right if you're in any relationship dude
it's just it's just more like how to be
a good person in a relationship like you
know what i have never seen anybody take
an approach like this ever i thought it
was great i was like how to
like party i woke up was this
oh it's a video i was like half asleep
that's kind of smart
i don't know we just i think it's smart
we had our 15-year anniversary and i was
just thinking like you know my dad never
one time when he was alive talk to me
about girl like he never talked to me
about having a family when we were about
to have a baby like we never talked
about it
so i was just
like you know what
i know a lot of other people are in that
predicament too and it's just like yeah
you know it's a milestone yeah it's it's
a great one and i mean obviously it
worked
it works you've been married for 15
years
you guys are [ __ ] friends
yeah it's like you guys are doing good
getting there she's used to me
the third baby really sealed it yeah
really locked her in with that lobster
um so yeah real quick just watch that
marty's youtube pages drastic graphics
and just try to build that up a little
bit watch this [ __ ] we got a couple more
oh yeah so
we uh
got a couple more extra days for us me
and marty to be working together now so
we're gonna be pumping a lot more
content out which brings me too much
flawlessly into the next point right
which brings me to my next topic
if you have not heard of it's called the
weed tube the we tube is an
app a website
just like youtube it was made by a bunch
of dudes that you should do or guys and
girls that used to do youtube weed [ __ ]
like me
but in 2015 they deleted all the
wetubers for some reason
and these guys got so upset that they
got the funding and made their own
[ __ ] app so they could not get
deleted ever again
[ __ ] that i will always say like i would
need my own app they did that so shout
out to the weed tube okay you know
download the app store whatever you want
to do it's pretty cool it's youtube for
just weed [ __ ]
and there's a yola category now so it's
pretty cool
and one category is just free all this
stuff
let me post on there for a minute anyway
marty and i did our very first video
besides the podcast we've never done a
video this is marty and i's first actual
video together and it's called
he only reacts to the internet with
drastic graphics because you know how to
do the you'll react to the internet
series on youtube
i thought what's some [ __ ] that we can't
really watch on youtube and or play
music so that's why we're like we tube
will let us let's go do uncensored [ __ ]
more on we tube so if you want to watch
that it's dopaziola on wetube and the
video is from me and marty it's got a
thumbnail of me and him you can't
[ __ ] miss it go watch that video
it's me i show marty music he's never
heard because he doesn't listen to new
music marty shows me music that
i've never heard because i've never
listened to the music he listened to
and i watched and we showed some stupid
[ __ ] it's a fun stupid [ __ ] we sat here
for hours
video's only 20 minutes long two and a
half hours we sat here filming and
editing and watching because me and him
just did a podcast we ended up starting
telling stories like no
we're supposed to be reacting well it's
an hour and a half in i said that go
dude we are [ __ ] up so this is the
wrong episode because me and him are so
used to just talking we just started
going into a podcast
so there's another podcast we just did
the other day for noth and we just ended
up only keeping a percentage only the
percentage that we kept was the stuff we
reacted to the rest of it we just i love
doing that was so fun it was fun more to
come all right maybe do the clips
channel too and what if we don't smoke
at all it'll be monetized
[Music]
it was nice having a uh gentleman's bong
on site yeah we had the [ __ ] bong on
there it was it was cool it was
different
that's not what we can do on youtube so
that's one other point i want to check
uh you guys check out the we tube check
out marty and i's video it's pretty
[ __ ] cool all right pretty [ __ ]
tight
um
all right all right on to my next my
next topic
here we
go
update i'm about to update you guys
right now what's going on
thedopashshop.com you guys already know
that's uh i'm partnered i'm not partner
i'm co-owner with my homies
adobeshop.com hhc hhc is the legal
version of thc that's why we're allowed
to ship it to all 50 states any city any
county any anything there is no illegal
place in the country
we've been doing really [ __ ] good all
right we got [ __ ] concentrates like
dab you can da and i know it sounds
crazy but yes we have dabs and they look
like the dabs you got maybe better
they look amazing
got disposables cards pre-rolls [ __ ]
edibles that i have to chill on because
they're strong as [ __ ] and i'm not just
saying that because it's our company
they're very strong they put me to
[ __ ] sleep i eat them at night only
and when i don't have [ __ ] to do the
next morning because i wake up [ __ ] up
it's weird it's like a uh edible
hangover and you've heard that
it sucks i'm not saying our [ __ ] sucks
i'm just saying i eat like 800
milligrams sometimes because they're as
good as [ __ ] let's eat candy and i go
bro what am i doing [ __ ] the bag's gone
yeah and then i'm done
because they're really good they are
[ __ ] good so that's the problem with
them
anyway i wanted to bring it up because i
feel like
because we've been deleted off instagram
six times just don't have our page back
we're working on getting our page back
anyway thedopashop.com all right it's
legal and we still get in trouble i mean
there's billboards up of it with my
[ __ ] face on it i still get deleted
off instagram for it and they delete all
my posts on instagram about it it's
crazy anyway that's what i want to talk
about here all right go check that [ __ ]
out it's pretty [ __ ] awesome and
legal so youtube don't get upset with me
100 legal
um yeah i just want to give you a little
quick update man
tell you about what's going on we're
getting ready to stop walking on these
goddamn mag shops with instagram too yes
yes
we're hinting at what was going to
happen we don't know what's going to
happen we're about to not have to be the
[ __ ] i'm sorry
i won't even ask for help sorry
instagram i'm not going to hit report no
no help center for me because they're
going to go who's helping he's showing
wheat deleted that's how i feel like if
i rep if i try to appeal anything go oh
you want to appeal [ __ ] you
because i've been leading so many times
what is the cause i don't know so i just
shut the [ __ ] up
all right i'm a [ __ ] uh
i'm i'm a single mother right now i'm
just like blind to all this [ __ ] you
know i have [ __ ] to do man
i didn't see that i need this job
that's how if you're an abusive
relationship thank you i'm an abusive
relationship might as well be a single
mother
like no
this stairs
i fell down the stairs no instagram
delete it's fine i'll make another one
leave me alone
i don't care anyway that's what's going
on tobyshop.com we can't talk about it
anywhere else stuff like in twitter and
snapchat and [ __ ] so i just want to talk
about it real quick
much more happening with that a lot of
stuff happening with that [ __ ] i'll give
you updates as it comes but
it's just awesome that new [ __ ]
honeydew flavors popping [ __ ]
honeydew flavors popping the honeydew is
so [ __ ] good
the rainbow sherbet so [ __ ] i it depends
on what you like the pens guys are
flying
it's so weird to see
and like see our [ __ ] at shops people
send me [ __ ] like oh gear on the wall oh
my god i am on your [ __ ] smoke shop
wall amazing is my face
it's weird my face is on the packaging
in the back hella small like a little
stamp uh-huh it's just weird to see it's
weird to see like our [ __ ] actually work
and grow so thank you guys for that um
hopefully getting that page back soon
that'd be cool that'd be cool um
up to my my last point actually what
where do we at
two perfect we're at my last point all
right and this is
something i want to talk to you guys
about because on this channel on this
show the dope as usual podcast one of
the fan favorites is og
you guys love og so [ __ ] much all
right and he still hasn't watched an
episode he's so [ __ ] scared
he's i'm actually gonna go there after
this and get some weed he's so [ __ ]
scared of watching his own [ __ ] you guys
should have seen him when we started
filming the episode about to tell you
hey man like is it hot like it's 64
degrees
sure
should we take a shot like you worry
about being hot you want to take a shot
i don't know man oh no you scared a
little girl don't worry little kid don't
worry
and then um so here's what happened i
told og
let's start a series on the dopaziola
channel so right now on the dopaziola
channel episode 1 is up the series is
called me and ogi all right it was going
to be called
the chronic critics it was going to be
called a bunch of other [ __ ] and then
one really i'm going to mention it
always because i thought it was really
funny
some racist ass funny ass fool out there
i was like yo you should call this show
baked beans
because you're high maxing it
that's what
it's funny
so funny i wish i would have thought of
it
but that's not what we're calling it i'm
calling it me and og because i thought
it was the easiest simplest thing
basically me and him are gonna review
things all right we're gonna review
stuff but i thought what if it's like
me and og
do shrooms and go grocery shopping
me and og go to the public library
stupid [ __ ]
but for now we're gonna do reviews so we
reviewed the freeze pipe and i asked in
the episode oh gee can you explain or uh
describe this bong elegantly
wait a minute like it's a bong
that's what he said to me
it took us
four
hours
to film og's section because i did all
the b-roll and all the close-ups after
he or before he got there so just so he
could walk in and not feel like oh
i just want him to sit down let's get it
done like stop break your anxiety fool
he he hates being on camera anyway
he sits down
uh the video was only 20 [ __ ] minutes
long and it took us four hours to get
his section cause he would not [ __ ]
stop
everything he said it was like bro no
you like we're doing a review okay okay
okay well it's like a bong like shut the
[ __ ] up and say it right and there's a
time like oh gee introduce this next
ball just say the freeze pipe 2022
version
15 minutes it took 15 minutes for him to
get that he wasn't even on camera it was
just his voice on an overlay and i told
him your face is not going to be on
camera
okay [ __ ] you're [ __ ] me up
there's a freeze pipe 20 oh my bro just
say two after 22 that's it you're fine
dude took so long i get it it's his
first time doing like camera besides the
podcast and you know it
we need just to get all the footage
that's the video yeah oh my god i just
started going all like [ __ ]
effort punched me in the ribs like 32
times shut up
like not hard but he's like
leave me alone
all i would do is just look at him and
he would just stop talking and start
laughing it was so [ __ ] hard you know
those friends you look at you're just
like you should have your i left
we're trying to film a video here's
nikita you like
stay there for [ __ ] a whole day to
film our video
because oh gee man
so anyway on the dopaziola channel many
more coming because it was so [ __ ]
hysterical to film it's so funny [ __ ]
with that bull we should just live
stream the filming of it
he would hate you so much he would hate
he still doesn't even watch that one
he's all i got 30 seconds in he started
making [ __ ] fun of me and i can't
watch my anxiety well i didn't make fun
of you watch it [ __ ] starts off with
hi it's me thomas and this is og
crickets literally call added cricket
noises i didn't say anything
it's not like pro say something oh you
didn't tell me i'm like i'm introducing
you
take two and i say it and he goes hi
shut the [ __ ] up and i kept it in there
and he was so upset because he was being
goofy i'm like full you're
people are going to find out sooner or
later that those glasses don't mean
you're scary even though you're scary
you can still be goofy too you can have
fun
you're loud that's so funny to me that
that's scary to him because you just
think like knowing him like that's just
[ __ ] funny he's such a goofy
[ __ ] but
he's serious too yeah but
it's just it was funny to film guys
wow
i'm [ __ ] high it was really funny to
film had a good time um
yeah go watch down the dopage channel me
and doji
i think
that's every single topic i wanted to
hit we should have og react to like read
like
historic events in history and react
horrible [ __ ]
oh there's something like you could say
things that he would say
it's ridiculous
off camera it's so much more ridiculous
it's way worse
like like when you're facetiming me the
other day and he was like he'll like pop
on doesn't start like talking to me
he'll like start saying something but
then he'll just stop talking and do
something else
this fool will stop mid-sentence hey
what do you think like yeah
sleeve
because he's at work he's doing stuff
i'm like yo why'd you even start the
i'm sorry marty i don't know what the
[ __ ] he was asking it's the weirdest
[ __ ] this fool is tripping
but like in a funny way but it's like
deliberate he's like [ __ ] with you
he's [ __ ] with you that's exactly
what's happening
he's such a fool every time i introduce
someone you gotta remember his fullness
nothing he's saying is true all right
just leave it at that
place he always says he's from is
zamunda zamunda is for the place from
coming to america
okay
every time everyone thinks he's from a
place called zamunda
he says it everything
leaves it at that
doesn't say anything
so
that's the kind of [ __ ] i had to always
like hey man don't [ __ ] with this waiter
yeah
we tweaked our food we [ __ ] with this
waiter yeah
we had this huge australian waiter at
dinner the other day giant guy terrible
waiter on one super on one took forever
to get back to our table
and oh gee just kept saying stupid [ __ ]
like oh gee bro he gots our food just
wait not being rude
he would bring like the forks after like
the eight time i asked him
and he goes
oh thanks man the forks thank you man
like oh dumb as [ __ ] and the guy's like
yeah okay i think you're welcome
and walked off and snorted a [ __ ]
line or some [ __ ] he was on one terrible
waiter
and uh
just [ __ ] like that because you know
he's also caught hey thanks man like all
over the top
sarcastically these forks are sharp
holes
[ __ ] like that
all the time he always asks for menudo
burritos we do those soup
how do you make a burrito
he asked for it everywhere and you see
people's faces
do we do hey do we it's like yo are you
[ __ ] stupid
think about what you just said let me
get that let me get that water sandwich
like did you exactly [ __ ] say water
sandwich next time and then you're going
to go oh he's [ __ ] with me
but me no g did date calls years ago we
need to bring it back
we just prank called people me and him
people we knew and we did a good job i
could see him being good at that
we did a good job guys
talking like very different you can see
with og like the [ __ ] tables turn and
the people you called end up like
[ __ ] having him on his heels
real quick you guys gotta watch it just
real quick before i wrap this up
what about g's good friends we knew he
had this job and he quit right and he
said they were [ __ ] dicks or
something stupid so he's like no [ __ ]
that they quit they fired me they said
they fired him
the prank call was og sets it up hey
what's up what are you doing mama oh
okay you know so see you later just like
a call it's me no g in his garage we're
filming this
and then i call because we know he's
going to a [ __ ] uh staffing center to
get a job his friend because he just got
fired from his job that he tells og this
whole elaborate story of why he got
fired why it's not [ __ ] right
so i call hello hi this is edgar
something something from staffing
something something oh gee knows where
the place he goes is his friend he knows
everything about what he's doing so he's
feeding me information and oh she's
dying laughing trying not to lose it and
i'm like oh hello so-and-so so i see
that you have your application here the
last place you worked blah blah blah
goes yeah man yeah
and i'm looking at og like this
it's like this folk doesn't give a [ __ ]
that i'm calling him for a job like we
would press me and go you're [ __ ]
home he's stupid he's like yeah what's
up bro that's how he was acting like
yeah job oh yeah so what do you got for
me yeah that's how he was acting dude
and i unmuted it go so uh we heard your
last job so tell me why you were like go
from that place
she straight up says
he's some stupid man
that's and i'm oh she's dying
under his breath just [ __ ]
and i'm pressing mute to laugh my ass
off like this is an interview listen to
how he's talking on you
so what was he like they wanted me to
move some boxes and like i'm not gonna
do that that's dumb so i quit
oh so you quit oh okay okay yeah
assistant you say quit on your
application okay he told a jesus
labrador story where they fired him for
some stuff that was taken
oh there's an elaborate story it turns
out he's like the one with some bot and
the way he said i mean it's on video it
was stupid i'm not gonna do that that's
basically what he said
so og calls i hang up like oh we'll let
you know about what i hang up after the
interview
and oh geez like so what's up we're
gonna smoke he's like yo i just got a
call
from his play staff he's like wait
staffing
he's always like and we just connected
the dots to where like wait you have
heard of that place oh she's like yeah
you should you should call him back bro
he's trying to get that job like we just
kept it going
and then i kept laughing so hard while
trying to when i called him back that i
kept pressing you
because i was laughing so hard so i can
let it out and then it kept going like
that
and i go
and i'm so sorry there's some uh bad
reception goes yeah man i think i'm just
going over some speed bumps so it's bad
reception that's what he said
legitimately and that's when i threw the
[ __ ] phone i couldn't take it anymore
we muted the [ __ ] i almost [ __ ] threw
up in my lap bro i was so much and at
the end when we revealed it to his ass
oh my god we ended up just giving him
like a half zip like yo here get a good
sport
we revealed it og called and it was me
on the line he goes wait a minute
are you so stupid
jesus christ i wanted to go you know
edgar too or something like you know oh
gee you know the staffing people
yo we called about packs for somebody
else
we did this whole elaborate thing and
the dude about the pack for that prank
call episode he didn't call you back for
like five days he was so pissed
but it was worth it
and then we prank called one of his own
other homies that's a teacher
oh my god we had him thinking that he we
found all his porn stash and all this
crazy on his [ __ ] computer we needed
to get it clean before all this stuff
and he was like no i swear man like no
it's not me
we want to call og shop because we know
everybody that works there and just
start so yeah i got on the phone with
the og manager and he said what do you
mean and then she used to speak running
back where's og wakataki from the
filming oh no no like no let him go let
him do it you know what i mean oh bro we
can go so far with the place that he
already works
for real i mean yeah he could terrorize
those [ __ ] people she really wants us
gave me like 500 cash back like i just
want to know who you give 500 to
oh my god i can see everything happen
sorry i know this is ranting forever i'm
giving away all my [ __ ] ideas and
[ __ ] sorry um my bad this is a long-ass
podcast sorry i just started talking
anyway damn marty this is a facetime
conversation uh-huh i should catch you
up for i should have stopped this like
15 minutes ago i'm so sorry guys
this is what i did on facetime here we
go thank you so much for being here
anyway it's called me and og oh marty
why did i do that
what a long rant
i just remembered everything i just
talked about
can you like pop up the dank calls
thumbnail or something for sure so i can
at least be like well these are talked
about
because i'm just over here rambling
historic relevant [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're giving the the prequel to the
[ __ ] nog yeah there you go okay thank
you that helps me feel better about it
so mario you have anything else you want
to say to everybody before we get out of
here
i don't know man i'm feeling pretty
[ __ ] good i've always found in life
that the really really really great the
biggest best [ __ ] happens right after
you go through really hard times
i've found that a bunch of times
we've been talking about that and it
just feels good
when things like when big coincidences
happen coincidences and it's like damn i
can't believe this timing of all this
[ __ ] is lining up like this
i just like to keep back and really
enjoy those wins because those days come
few and far in between when you're in
this [ __ ] so you got to feel good about
the wins
you go back there you take all the
losses on the chin celebrate the [ __ ]
wins yeah and just like with all things
we're just gonna keep trying to level
this thing up
until we get to the very top of this
[ __ ] and then
push forward
perfect yeah i like it he has that whole
thing tatted on his back too yeah no
yeah everywhere i'm reading that off the
screen
that's a lyric
it was actually it was a dmx song i just
[ __ ] read yeah like the annie
rough
that feels weird to say that was weird
i haven't heard that in a minute yeah
that was weird
holy [ __ ] that's so odd that he yeah
he's [ __ ] gone yeah it is all my all
my favorite rappers are gone it's [ __ ]
up it is [ __ ] up
well
anyway guys
we'll get out of here on that sad note
thank you for being here if you've been
driving if you've been driving and
listening on spotify do not watch and
drive
please be safe just because this video
doesn't mean you have to [ __ ] watch
it it'll seamlessly integrate with the
audio version yeah just listen please be
safe i don't want you [ __ ] oh what is
he showing and you crash please be safe
okay this is perfect last thing we need
with this [ __ ] spotify deal working i
know dude so many people you've talked
we've talked about it's an ongoing theme
we're at like 15 car accidents now
[ __ ] like i was laughing just
listen to the [ __ ] i [ __ ] crash
pc [ __ ]
um
yeah that's the first solo in a while
hell yeah thank you guys for coming here
shout out to miller life for sponsoring
this [ __ ] episode
thank you guys so much for being here we
appreciate it go watch the clips channel
dope as usual podcast clips on youtube
before you leave if you're watching no
matter where you're watching please do
us a favor click the [ __ ] like button
it helps all right if i can help so
thank you guys so much for being here uh
dope as usual podcast dot com dope is
yolo.com pushtrees.com thedopashop.com
jesus christ there's a lot uh
yeah refer to that new [ __ ] uh intro
screen on the dopaziola videos because
15 accounts there's so many channels
that's crazy it's ridiculous but
it's fun and they all have a use so
thank you guys so much for being here
this has been
another episode another solo episode our
favorites to do every [ __ ] time i
love talking to guests this is my
favorite [ __ ] it's the garage talk we're
just hanging out and just talking [ __ ]
so thank you guys so much for being here
this has been another episode of the
dobas usual podcast i am thomas
dobasiolo whatever you want to call me
this is marty o'neil from both of us in
this boxed ass room have a dope s day
all right
all right
those joints worked out perfect
perfect
[Music]